Herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast der Metaebene in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Zeiss Großplanetarium in Berlin. Ich begrüße alle hier zur 61. Ausgabe und aufregende Zeiten in der Raumfahrt und auch ein wenig aufregende Zeiten hier für Raumzeit. Nach 61 Folgen geht es hier auch das erste Mal um Raumzeit. Konkret möchte ich heute einsteigen in die Welt der Gravitationswellen und alles Mögliche an Projekten vorstellen, was damit zu tun hat und ganz konkret auch über eine neue Mission reden, die einerseits in der Zukunft liegt und andererseits auch schon aktiv getestet werden soll. Nämlich die Mission Lisa bzw. Lisa Pathfinder. Um hier mal ordentlich die Raumzeit zu krümmen, begrüße ich zunächst einmal Oliver Jendrich. Hallo, schönen guten Tag. Ja Oliver, wir sitzen in Darmstadt gerade. Das ist nicht unbedingt deine Homebase. Du bist hier am ISA-Kontrollzentrum, sondern im ASTEC, nicht wahr?
Ja, das stimmt. Ich bin normalerweise am ASTEC in Nordwijk in den Niederlanden. Ich bin eigentlich ganz früher, ich bin Hannover geboren, Hannover aufgewachsen, aber ich bin hier schon seit über zehn Jahren in den Niederlanden und arbeite dort am Europäischen Space Technology Center, der ISA, das ASTEC.
Genau, das war ja hier auch schon häufiger Thema. Ich hab das auch schon ein paar Mal besucht. Das ist ja der Ort, wo vor allem viel getestet wird, aber eben auch sehr viel Development gemacht wird. Starten wir doch vielleicht mal erstmal mit dir. Also Hannover hast du gestartet, aber seit wann ist denn Raumfahrt dein Thema?
Ja, ich hab in Hannover Physik studiert und so ein Studium schließt man mit der Diplomarbeit ab. Und als ich damals herumgeschaut habe, was es denn so für Themen gibt, die mich vielleicht interessieren könnten, da kam das Gespräch auf bodengestützte Gravitationswellendetektoren. Die fingen damals in Deutschland gerade an, das war 1992. Und da hab ich dann eine kleine Aufgabe bekommen, einfach doch mal auszurechnen, was es denn da für Effekte gibt, was es für Neues, für Rauschquellen gibt und was man dagegen vielleicht tun kann. Und nachdem ich mit der Diplomarbeit fertig war, bin ich sozusagen in dem Thema drin geblieben. Ich hab dann weiter in dem Bereich gearbeitet und hab dann auch mit einer Arbeit über Rauschquellen am Gravitationswellendetektor promoviert. Und ja, wenn man dann erstmal so drin ist in dem Thema, dann lässt man das nicht so richtig los. Es hat dann relativ bald Vorschläge gegeben, ernsthafte Vorschläge, so einen Gravitationswellendetektor auch im All zu bauen. Und das hat mich dann auch sehr interessiert. Ich hab dann zwei Jahre war ich in den USA und habe da auf dem Bereich gearbeitet. Und dann bin ich nach Europa zurückgekommen, nach Glasgow in Schottland. Und bin dann letztlich bei der ESA gelandet, als dann klar wurde, dass die ESA, das war 2002, dass dann klar wurde, dass die ESA doch in der mittelbaren Zukunft zu einem Detektor fliegen möchte. Das hat dann alles, dauert dann alles etwas länger, als man sich das ursprünglich vorstellt. Aber wir sehen ja jetzt gerade durch, wir haben letztes Jahr Lisa Pathfinder in den Orbit gebracht. Es geht voran.
Ja, es geht voran. Man muss dazu sagen, wir haben jetzt Mitte Februar und die letzte Woche war gefühlt der helle Wahnsinn in eurem Feld, oder? Kann man nicht anders sagen, oder?
Ja, also so Rückblick muss man sagen. Mich persönlich hat das Medienecho doch dann schon etwas überrascht. Sehr positiv überrascht. Gut, wenn man selber so drinsteckt in dem Thema, dann ist das natürlich was Besonderes für einen, dass da jetzt nach 100 Jahren nach der Vorhersage durch Albert Einstein, dass es dann Gravitationswellen geben könnte, dass die tatsächlich auch mal gemessen werden und sagen wir mal so rund 40 Jahre nachdem die ersten Versuche mit interferometrischen Detektionen angefangen haben, dass das dann auch tatsächlich funktioniert hat. Dass das dann auch ein solches Medienecho findet, fand ich einerseits sehr schön, auf der anderen Seite total überraschend.
Man ist es nicht mehr so richtig gewohnt, dass Wissenschaft wirklich The News ist, weil es immer sehr komplexe Themenfelder sind. Und gerade das Thema Gravitationswellen hat glaube ich viele lange Zeit ja irgendwie sehr verstört, weil es war ja sozusagen auch die Suche nach etwas, von dem man dann letzten Endes ja nicht wirklich weiß, ob man es überhaupt jemals empfangen kann. Oder manche meinten das vielleicht, dass es auf jeden Fall so sei, aber der Beweis musste sozusagen erstmal angetreten werden. Aber ich denke wir haben gerade in den letzten Jahren einfach so eine erhöhte Dichte an Wissenschaftsmeldungen gehabt, gerade so im letzten Jahr, dass man sich jetzt schon wieder ein bisschen dran gewöhnt hat, dass die Wissenschaft solche Durchbrüche liefern kann.
Ja, es gibt immer so Sachen, da denkt man so, das ist sicherlich was, was jeden total interessiert. Also wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel in eine kleine Sonde auf dem Kometen landen, da ist jeder total interessiert dran. Weil da kann man mitfiebern, da weiß man, das ist ein kleines Stück Metall, was da landet und dann irgendwas macht.
Hat einen Namen, das piept.
Hat einen Namen, das hat einen Pieps, das hat einen schönen Comic, da kann man kleine Cartoons drüber zeichnen und so. Und das kommt total gut an bei allen, das ist einfach so. Und dann gibt es halt Sachen, die sind sehr viel schwieriger zu vermitteln, weil sie doch extrem abstrakt sind. Ich kann Gravitationswellen schlecht hinmalen und ihnen ein kleines Gesicht hinmalen oder Sprechblasen dran oder so. Das ist dann schon ein anderer Abstraktionsgrad. Und wie gesagt, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass das so ankommt. Andererseits muss ich auch sagen, die Kollegen haben sich in den letzten 10, 15 Jahren extrem viel Mühe gegeben, vernünftige Visualisierungen zu machen, sodass man sich das auch mal anschauen kann auf dem Computer. Und sich einfach mal auch mal ganz platt dran freuen kann, dass sowas auch mal ganz nett aussehen kann, wenn da zwei schwarze Löcher miteinander verschmelzen und da Wellen abgesendet werden. Und das dann in allen schönen Farben, Falschfarben natürlich, aber immerhin angezeigt wird. Das hat dann auch vielleicht was Ästhetisches. Trotzdem, ich war wie gesagt extrem positiv überrascht über das große Medienecho.
Ja, dann versuchen wir nochmal ein bisschen hinter die Kulissen zu blicken, um überhaupt zu verstehen, was eigentlich passiert ist. Zunächst einmal, es geht um Schwerkraft. Es geht um das, was so ein bisschen die Welt zusammenhält. Also unsere Welt zumindest. Sonst würden wir nicht irgendwie um die Sonne rotieren. Und das Verständnis von Schwerkraft durch die Menschen war ja ein langer Prozess. Und der Durchbruch kam, wie schon erwähnt, durch Albert Einstein. Was ist Einstein eigentlich im Rahmen seiner Arbeiten an der Relativitätstheorie klar geworden? Was war da auch vor allem neu? Und was waren die Aussagen, die jetzt auch für unsere Geschichte so interessant waren?
Also ich glaube, die wesentliche Erkenntnis von Einstein, die über das hinausgeht, was man vorher natürlich durch Newton schon alles wusste, die Planetenbahnen, kann man auch ohne Einstein ziemlich gut beschreiben. Aber das Wesentliche Neue, was bei Einstein dazu gekommen ist, war denke ich die Erkenntnis, dass es eigentlich gar keine Rolle spielt, ob man von der Erde angezogen wird, also der Schwerkraft unterliegt, oder ob man sonst wie beschleunigt wird. Dass diese beiden Effekte, also eine Beschleunigung und die Erdanziehung oder die Schwerkraft eigentlich äquivalent sind. Dass man die auch äquivalent beschreiben kann. Und daraus aus dieser eigentlich recht simplen Erkenntnis, wo sich vielleicht Rückblicken jeder sagt, meine Güte, so bahnbrechend war das ja nicht. Das ist ja vielleicht was, was man dann auch schon mal erfahren hat, dass man im Fahrstuhl schnell nach unten fährt, dass man sich vielleicht ein bisschen leichter fühlt. Aber das war halt eine bahnbrechende Erkenntnis. Und allein auf dieser Erkenntnis lassen sich extrem viele Dinge zunächst erstmal auf mathematischer Basis entwickeln und dann auch schauen, ob das dann so in der Wirklichkeit auch tatsächlich so ist. Ob die Theorie, die man sich da zusammengebaut hat, dann in der Natur, der Überprüfung in der Natur auch standhält. Und gut, es gibt natürlich diese sogenannten, ja, diese Schlüsseleffekte der Gravitation, der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie, die zum Beispiel die Lichtablenkung im Schwerefeld, die es unter Newton, wenn man sich das genau überlegt oder mit ein bisschen Fantasie da dran geht, eigentlich auch schon gibt, aber halt um Faktor zwei weniger. Und die berühmte Eddington-Expedition 1919, wo der Arthur Eddington dann die Verschiebung der Sterne im Schwerefeld der Sonne während einer Sonnenfinsternis vermessen hat, das war ja sozusagen die erste experimentelle Bestätigung der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie.
Ganz kurz, können wir das vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen aufhören? Also was heißt das? Beschleunigung und Schwerkraft ist dasselbe. Was ist da die eigentliche Erkenntnis?
Also die Legende geht ja, dass Einstein im Fahrstuhl gestanden hat und festgestellt hat, wenn jetzt die Seile reißen würden und der Fahrstuhl im freien Fall nach unten fällt, dann würde das für ihn im Fahrstuhl zumindest für einen kurzen Moment so aussehen, als wäre er schwerelos. Weil er genauso mit der gleichen Geschwindigkeit und der gleichen Beschleunigung fällt wie der Fahrstuhl. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo er auf den Fußboden schaut oder an die Decke schaut, stellt er fest, dass in Bezug zu diesem Fahrstuhlsystem er nicht mehr beschleunigt wird. Das gesamte System wird beschleunigt mit ihm drin, aber die relative Beschleunigung wäre halt null. Und daraus dann die Erkenntnis zu haben, das ist ja genauso wie im freien Fall. Das ist genauso, als wenn wir, wir müssen da denken, das war bevor wir Satelliten im Orbit hatten, 50 Jahre vor Sputnik, ganz sicher keine Erfahrung mit Astronauten in der ISS. Aber das wäre ja genauso, als wenn wir irgendwo etwas mitten im Weltall im freien Fall hätten. Da wären wir auch schwerelos. Und das liegt einfach nur daran, dass alles mit der gleichen Rate fällt. Also die Sachen, alle Körper fallen gleich schnell. Das ist ja nun auch schon was, was angeblich Galileo mit den Fallversuchen vom Schiefenturm von Pisa gemacht hat. Gut, die hat er nicht wirklich gemacht, weil er dazu zu clever war, gewusst, dass das wird nichts. Aber er hat Experimente gemacht, die ihm davon überzeugt haben, dass alles mit der gleichen Geschwindigkeit fällt oder mit der gleichen Beschleunigung fällt. Und die Erkenntnis von Einstein war halt dieser Schluss, das ist ja wie im freien Fall, wenn man dann zusammen mit den Sachen fällt. Und dass es eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied macht, wie man es beschreibt. Und wenn es keinen Unterschied macht, wie man es beschreibt, dann ist das auch das Gleiche. Auch das war ein, sozusagen wissenschaftlich, wissenschaftshistorisch sicherlich ein großer Schritt. Nun weiß ich nicht, ob Einstein...
Dass Beschleunigung und Fall dasselbe ist.
Und die Erkenntnis, wenn man zwei Dinge hat, die sich in der Beschreibung nicht voneinander unterscheiden. Dann sind das die gleichen Dinge. Dass man sagt, wenn ich jetzt im freien Fall bin und ich gar nicht, wenn ich zum Beispiel in diesem Fahrstuhl eingesperrt bin, der jetzt abstürzt, dann kann ich während ich in dem Fahrstuhl bin eigentlich nur sagen, die Schwerkraft ist weg. Ich bin im freien Fall. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das daran liegt, dass um mich herum überhaupt gar keine Masse ist, dass ich eben mitten im Weltall treibe und es keine Schwerkraft gibt, weil keine Masse in der Nähe ist oder weil ich durch eine große Masse wie die Erde angezogen werde, aber mit dem Fahrstuhl zusammenfalle. Gut, in diesem Falle endet natürlich die Äquivalenz beim Aufprall, relativ harsh, aber zumindest theoretisch im Gedankenexperiment kann man sich natürlich vorstellen, dass man sich beliebig lange in einem solchen feilenden Fahrstuhl befindet und alle möglichen Experimente machen kann, sich überlegen kann, was für ein Experiment kann ich jetzt machen, um zu unterscheiden, ob ich mitten im Weltall bin, wo keine Masse um mich herum ist, oder ob ich im freien Fall bin. Und da stellt sich heraus, da kann ich noch so gute Experimente machen, wenn ich auf einen kleinen Bereich in diesem Fahrstuhl beschränkt bin und keine Fenster habe, in denen ich nach draußen schauen kann, kann ich diese beiden Szenarien nicht von einem unterscheiden. Und in dem Fall muss man sagen, und wenn ich sie nicht unterscheiden kann, dann sind es letztendlich die gleichen Bedingungen. Dann ist es die gleiche Situation. Ich denke, das ist auch so von der philosophischen, vom philosophischen Bereich eine Sache, die, denke ich mal, vor Einstein so ausgeprägt noch nicht gesagt worden ist, dass man sagt, also dieser berühmte englische Spruch, if it looks like a duck, if it quacks like a duck, it's a duck. Das ist halt etwas, was man auch erstmal sozusagen verinnerlichen muss und auch verstehen muss, dass sich Dinge nur durch Messungen voneinander unterscheiden kann. Und wenn es keine Messungen gibt, keine denkbare Messung gibt, die zwei Dinge voneinander unterscheiden können, dann sind diese beiden Dinge auch gleich. Ich denke, das war eine zentrale Erkenntnis, die auch Einstein dann letztlich dazu geführt hat, dieses Gedankengebäude zu entwickeln. Obwohl, ich muss fairerweise sagen, ich bin weit davon entfernt, ein geübter Einsteinausleger zu sein. Also, da gibt es sicherlich tiefer gehende Arbeiten, die die Philosophie und die Gedankenbeute Einsteins noch tiefer durchleuchten, als das, was ich darüber weiß.
Was hat denn das geändert an der Sichtweise, wie man dachte, wie Schwerkraft funktioniert? Im Prinzip war ja, wenn ich das richtig sehe, war ja Newton eigentlich der erste, der sozusagen diese ganze Schwerkraft mal so richtig aufgearbeitet hat, aber einfach als Phänomen erst mal nur so zur Kenntnis genommen hat, ohne eine Aussage darüber zu machen, warum die da ist und wodurch sie eigentlich wirkt, sondern nur, dass sie da ist.
Ja, also ich denke mal, die zentrale Unterschied dort ist, dass in Einsteins Theorie die Schwerkraft einfach eine Auswirkung der Geometrie des Raumes ist. Nun, der Geometrie des Raumes, das hört sich ganz schrecklich mystisch und kompliziert an, aber letztendlich bedeutet das nichts anderes, als dass alles, was im freien Fall ist, zum Beispiel der Mond um die Erde oder die Erde um die Sonne oder auch die Sonne um das Zentrum unserer Milchstraße, bewegt sich auf geraden Linien. Und dann weiß man aber, die Erde ist doch mehr oder weniger im Kreis um die Sonne. Wie kann das dann eine gerade Linie sein? Aber gerade Linie in diesem Zusammenhang bedeutet eigentlich nur, es nimmt den kürzesten Weg von einem Punkt zum anderen Punkt. Und was der kürzeste Weg ist von einem Punkt zum anderen Punkt, das hängt halt davon ab, wie der Raum geformt ist. Man kann sich das auf einer Kugel vorstellen. Wenn man sich einen Globus einfach mal nimmt und vom Nordpol zum Südpol möchte, auf dem kürzesten Weg, dann kann man da eine Linie ziehen. Und wenn man sich das anguckt, dann sieht man, das ist ein Halbkreis. Aber das ist die kürzeste Linie, weil die Geometrie des Globus das hergibt. Nur wenn das jetzt kein Globus ist, sondern ein Apfel oder eine Apfelsine oder eine Banane oder irgendetwas, was ein Loch hat, zum Beispiel eine Tasse mit Henkel, und sie sitzen auf der Innenseite des Henkels und wollen auf die andere Seite der Tasse, dann kann man sich einen kürzesten Weg überlegen. Das ist kein Problem, aber wenn du dir das anschaust, das ist keine Gerade mehr. Das ist nur noch der kürzeste Weg. Und das ist die Erkenntnis, dass sich alles im Universum, was sich kräftefrei bewegt, im freien Fall ist, das ist das gleiche, kräftefrei und freier Fall, bewegt sich auf kürzesten Wegen. Diese kürzesten Wege, traditionell nennen wir die Geodäten, aber das ist ein Fachbegriff, der an der Stelle nicht so schrecklich wichtig ist. Da geht es wirklich nur darum, der kürzeste Weg, und wenn ich mir das auf der Zeichenebene vorstelle, dann ist der kürzeste Weg zwischen zwei Punkten. Wenn man da einen Bleistift nimmt, dann weiß man, das ist millennial, und dann ist das der kürzeste Weg zwischen zwei Punkten. In der normalen Geometrie ist das halt eine Gerade. Da gibt es dann so die Sache, ja, da bewegt sich in der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie alles auf Geraden. Ich denke, geschickter ist vielleicht die Formulierung auf kürzesten Wegen. Und der Unterschied zwischen Einsteinsbild und Newton's Bild ist, dass Newton tatsächlich die Gravitation als Phänomen verstanden hat. Er hat gesagt, ich habe Gravitation. Die Masse, die ich habe, zieht sich an. Und deswegen fängt der Apfel zu Boden. Und die Erde kreist um die Sonne. Und damit kann ich Planetenbahnen verstehen, damit kann ich ganz viele Dinge verstehen. Und Einsteinserkenntnis war halt, ja, so sieht das halt aus. Aber der etwas tiefer gehende Grund ist, dass sich diese Objekte alle auf kürzesten Wegen befinden. Und damit hat man sofort, also eins der frühen Erkenntnisse oder eines der frühen Ergebnisse von Einstein war ja das Voranschreiten des Merkur-Orbits, wo also der Merkur hat einen elliptischen Orbit um die Sonne und der dichteste Punkt, den der Merkur zur Sonne hat, der ist nicht stabil im Raum, sondern der läuft selber ein wenig um. Also diese Ellipse, die der Merkur um die Sonne beschreibt, die läuft um. Und diese sogenannte Progression, die kann man ausrechnen, klassisch mit Newton, da kann man sagen, das liegt daran, dass die ganzen anderen Planeten da auch noch dran rumzerren. Das stimmt auch, ein großer Teil dessen kann man dadurch erklären, das meiste durch Jupiter, aber eben nicht alles. Und in dem Moment, wo man die Theorie hatte und sagt, das sind ja eigentlich kürzeste Wege und nicht unbedingt Kreise oder Ellipsen, hat man ein Werkzeug gehabt, nochmal genau nachzugucken, wie denn der kürzeste Weg dort eigentlich ausschaut. Und dann hat Einstein festgestellt, ja, den fehlenden Effekt, den wir bisher nicht erklären konnten, den können wir jetzt erklären damit. Ja, und ich denke, das ist also der wesentliche Unterschied. In der Einsteinsten Theorie bewegen sich Körper auf kürzesten Strecken. Und wenn man das dann verallgemeinert, auf das gesamte Universum zum Beispiel, auf einmal kann man sich auch überlegen, wie sich denn ein, sagen wir mal, ein Gas, ein homogenes Gas im Universum verhält. Etwas, also wenn man alle Materie im Universum nimmt, kleinschreddert und gleichmäßig verteilt, dann kann man sich überlegen, was passiert denn jetzt? Ich habe das jetzt hier und dann anschaulich sagt, die Anschauung sagt einem natürlich, ja, wenn ich jetzt hier ein Gas habe und das sitzt da einfach nur rum, dann gibt es vielleicht drei Möglichkeiten. Die eine Möglichkeit ist, das zieht sich gegenseitig an und fällt wieder zusammen. Die andere Möglichkeit ist, es dehnt sich halt immer aus, weil wir wissen, Gase haben eigentlich die Tendenz, sich auszudehnen. Oder vielleicht macht es auch gar nichts und bleibt einfach da sitzen und alles kompensiert sich. Das sind drei verschiedene Szenarien, die kann man mit der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie beschreiben. Und dann kann man sich überlegen, welche Konsequenzen hat das? Und Einstein hat damals zum Beispiel gesagt, das ist auch ein schönes Beispiel, wie sehr eine Welt sich durch Messergebnisse geformt wird. Zu Einsteins Zeiten galt es eigentlich als gesichert, dass das Universum immer während und statisch ist. Und erst Mitte der 20er Jahre hat dann der Edwin Hubble festgestellt, dass die Galaxien sich von uns entfernen. Und zwar je schneller, desto weiter sie schon von uns entfernt sind. Und das hat Einstein aber noch nicht gewusst. Das war ein Messergebnis, das kam erst später. Das heißt, Einstein hatte eine Theorie, die eigentlich hervorragend diese Ausdehnung beschreiben würde, aber eine Natur, die sich dieser Beschreibung etwas widersetzt hat. Und er hat deswegen diese berühmte kosmologische Konstante eingeführt, die man dann hinschreiben kann und sagen, na ja, wenn ich die auf den richtigen Wert stelle, dann bleibt das alles statisch. Das hat er ja angeblich später als die größte Eselei in seinem Leben bezeichnet. Da weiß man auch nicht, ob das so genau stimmt. Aber das ist halt eine Sache. Er hat eine Theorie, die das Universum nicht so beschreibt, wie man es glaubt, zu verstehen. Und dann ändert man die Theorie etwas ab, sodass sie das beschreibt. Na ja, gut, wenn die Natur in die Ecke kommt und sagt, na ja, wenn du mal genauer hingeguckt hättest, dann hättest du schon gesehen, dass sich das Universum ausdehnt. Was dann ja auch im wesentlichen zehn Jahre nach der Allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie der Edwin Hubble auch nachgemessen hat. Und was letztlich natürlich noch eine schönere Bestätigung war, dass die originale Theorie eigentlich das Universum sehr viel besser beschreibt als die leicht modifizierte Theorie.
Die originale Theorie?
Die originale Allgemeine Relativität, die Feldgleichung der Allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie enthielten in der ursprünglichen Version diese kosmologische Konstante nicht. Die hat Einstein später dazugefügt, um ein statisches Universum zu erklären. Die ist dann interessanterweise im Wesentlichen wieder verschwunden, weil man ja einen Ausdien sich aus dem Universum hat. Sie ist jetzt wieder da, weil man jetzt durch die Kosmologie, durch Beobachtungen, durch den Planck-Satelliten, durch den amerikanischen WMAP-Satelliten und durch Supernova-Beobachtungen festgestellt hat, dass sich das Universum nicht nur ausdehnt, sondern auch beschleunigt ausdehnt. Das heißt, dann hat man sie auf einmal wieder da. Und kein Mensch weiß, wo die genau herkommt. Das ist eine andere Frage.
Also irgendwie hat Einstein alles relativ gut erfüllt. Und ein gutes Bild dafür gehabt.
Es ist eine sehr schöne, in sich geschlossene Theorie. Und die Natur hält sich da sehr gut dran.
Alles richtet sich nach Einstein. Um es vielleicht noch mal zusammenzufassen, was jetzt hier eigentlich die Kernerkenntnis ist. Zunächst einmal freier Pfeil, Beschleunigung ist dasselbe. Alles möchte auf dem kürzesten Weg irgendwo hinkommen. Das heißt aber nicht, dass es sich in Graden bewegt, sondern die Dinge rotieren umeinander. Das heißt, überall werden Kreise und Ellipse gezogen. Und das bedeutet dann wiederum, wenn der Weg der Kürzeste ist, aber das Ergebnis keine Gerade ist, dann ist das, worin man sich bewegt, nicht gerade.
Dann ist das, worin man sich bewegt, nicht gerade, sondern nicht flach, sondern gekrümmt. Das heißt, der Raum ist gekrümmt. Das ist ja vielleicht auch schon fast allgemein wissend, dass die gekrümmten Räume und die Schwerkraft der Ausdruck der Raumkrümmung sind. Und Massen krümmen den Raum. Und je nachdem, wie der Raum gekrümmt ist, so bewegen sich die Massen. Das sind die Schlüsselaussagen der Allgemeinrelativitätstheorie. Also gibt es den berühmten Spruch, dass Massen krümmen den Raum und der Raum sagt den Massen, wo sie sich lang zu bewegen haben. Diese Interaktion zwischen Masse und Raum ist auch eine zentrale Erkenntnis der Allgemeinrelativitätstheorie. Zwar die beiden nicht alleine isoliert betrachten kann. Ich habe hier den Raum und da lege ich jetzt mal ein paar Massen rein und dann wird schon alles gut, sondern das muss alles zusammenpassen. Also man kann nicht beliebig den Raum krümmen und dann irgendwo Massen reinlegen, sondern die Massen machen das dann schon. Die krümmen den Raum dann schon und dann sagt der Raum auch, wo die Massen hin müssen.
Gut, das ist jetzt die Erkenntnis, dass das so ist. Der Raum ist irgendwie gekrümmt. Ich meine, es gibt ja verschiedene greifbare Bilder. Das Einfachste ist sicherlich das gespannte Gummien.
Das berühmte Gummienuniversum in der Tat.
Genau, wo man halt eine schwere Kugel reinlegt und dann kann man schon mal so einen Sonnenumlauf ganz gut nachvollziehen. Ich hab jetzt in letzter Zeit immer häufiger so Schwämme im Kopf, die man so zerquetscht oder die sich von innen heraus zusammenziehen durch Feuchtigkeit oder Trockenheit. Weil ja im Prinzip auch da so erst die lineare Struktur, also der Poren, so wie ich sie am Anfang sehe und in dem Moment, wo ich das Ding zusammendrücke, ist halt dieser Porenverlauf eben ein anderer. Und so stelle ich mir das irgendwie immer vor. Die Frage ist natürlich jetzt, wie funktioniert das? Also ich meine, wie kann eine Masse, die jetzt irgendwo rumliegt wie die Sonne, diesen Raum krümmen? Was tut diese Masse mit diesem Raum? Wenn da eine Interaktion ist, dann muss es ja auch irgendein Interaktionsmittel geben.
Also da muss ich dich vielleicht enttäuschen. Das ist die Frage nach dem Wie. Das ist immer so eine heimtückische Frage für Physiker und Astronomen. Die können wir nämlich immer gar nicht so gut beantworten. Wir sind eigentlich immer ganz zufrieden damit, dass wir beantworten können, was passiert. Warum irgendwas so ist, das ist dann immer so eine kleine Frage, wo man sich fragen muss, wie sinnvoll ist die Frage anhand der Messwerte oder der Daten, die wir gerade haben. Können wir sagen, warum genau, also was ist genau der tiefere Grund, dass die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie so gut auf die Welt passt? Ich glaube, wenn man ehrlich ist, muss man sagen, das wissen wir nicht. Wir stellen fest, dass sie verflixt gut passt. Wir freuen uns darüber, dass wir damit sehr viele Sachen vorhersagen können und damit auch andere Sachen uns erschließen können. Die tiefe Frage nach dem genau, was dort warum passiert, ist schwierig und meist nicht so richtig gut zu beantworten. Man kann sich dann manchmal damit rausreden, wenn man die nächst umfassendere Theorie hat. Also wenn man jetzt eine Theorie hätte, in die man die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie einbetten könnte. Man sagt, bei ganz hohen Energien, wo wir heute bereits wissen, dass die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie vermutlich falsch sein wird. Wenn man jetzt zu extrem kleinen Abständen geht, zu extrem hohen Energien, also zum Beispiel die Phänomene, die unmittelbar nach dem Urknall vorgeherrscht haben. Da sind wir uns nicht hundertprozentig sicher, dass man das mit der allgemeinen Relativitätstheorie beschreiben könnte. Wenn man da seine Theorie hätte, in die man die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie sozusagen einbetten könnte, dann kann man natürlich den Trick machen und sagen, ah ja, jetzt weiß ich, warum das so ist. Weil jetzt habe ich eine Theorie, die das hat, aber dann ist die nächste Frage, warum ist diese Theorie richtig? Warum ist immer schwierig? Wir sind eigentlich, wie gesagt, immer ganz glücklich, wenn wir das Wie halbwegs beantworten können. Was passiert, wenn ich das und das mache? Oder was passiert, wenn folgende Bedingungen vorliegen?
Aber es muss doch irgendeine Theorie geben.
Theorien gibt es viele.
Aber die Schwertkraft, das weiß man, dehnt sich auch mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit aus. Wenn jetzt irgendwie die Sonne verschwinden würde, dann...
Wir würden das ungefähr acht Minuten später feststellen. An wesentlichen zwei Effekten. Erst wird es dunkel. Dann wird die Erde nicht mehr durch die Schwerkraft auf der Bahn gehalten. Die Raumkrummung ist dann eine andere. Die Erde würde in der Richtung, in der sie sich jetzt bewegt, geradeaus weiter bewegen. Da würden wir uns vielleicht ein paar Stunden darüber freuen. Dann hat sich das auch erledigt. Ohne Sonnenlicht passiert hier auf der Erde nicht so viel. Die Schwerkraft breitet sich nach allgemeiner Relativitätstheorie mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit aus. Wir empfinden Schwerkraft als statische Kraft. Du sitzt auf deinem Stuhl und das ist ja nichts, was sich ausbreitet. Du sitzt da und wenn du nicht aufstehst, dann bleibst du da sitzen. Tennisbälle fallen zu Boden oder solche Dinge. Das ist ja eine recht statische Sache. Von Licht wissen wir oder von den elektromagnetischen Phänomenen. Da unterscheiden wir immer so zwischen statischer Elektrizität. Das ist das, was dann die Haare zu Berge stehen lässt, wenn man sich morgens den Pullover anzieht. Oder wenn man das ist, dann einem in den Finger pitzelt, wenn man die Klinke anfasst. Und Elektrodynamik, das ist im Prinzip das, was wir normalerweise als Licht bezeichnen. Das ist im tiefsten Inneren dasselbe Phänomen. Das lässt sich alles ganz hervorragend mit der gleichen Mathematik beschreiben. Und wir reden dann von elektromagnetischen Feldern. Da haben wir die klare Unterscheidung zwischen statisch und dynamisch. Und da sagen wir, Licht breitet sich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit aus. Bei statischer Elektrizität reden wir nicht so richtig von Ausbreitung. Bei Gravitation reden wir eigentlich auch nicht so richtig von Ausbreitung, auch dass es statisch ist. Die Gravitation zieht dich einfach an, die ist dort. Jetzt ist die Frage, was ist passiert, wenn sich Gravitation... Was ist denn das Äquivalent zu Licht in der Gravitation? Wenn wir sagen, Gravitation, die schwere Anziehung, das ist so was wie statische Elektrizität, wo finde ich denn das Phänomen des Lichts, des sich ausbreitenden Phänomens? Und da haben wir Gravitationswellen. Das hat Einstein schon relativ früh erkannt, dass seine Theorie eigentlich auch, die ist mathematisch der Elektrodynamik sehr ähnlich, eigentlich auch ganz zwanglos Lösungen zulässt, die sich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit ausbreiten, also Wellen, wellenförmig ausbreiten. Und er hat auch relativ früh erkannt, dass man, was man dazu braucht, um die auszusenden, nämlich beschleunigte Massen. Zum Beispiel die Erde, die um die Sonne kreist, der Mond, der um die Erde umläuft oder jemand, der seine Hände wedelt. Oder von mir aus auch der Tennisball beim Aufschlag oder so was. Das sind alles beschleunigte Massen, die strahlen Gravitationswellen ab. Und Einstein hat aber auch gleich erkannt, dass dadurch, dass die Gravitationskonstante, also das, was die Kraft sozusagen, dass einem sagt, wie stark die Kraft auf einen wirkt, das ist eine sehr kleine Zahl im Vergleich mit allen anderen Naturkonstanten. Und das heißt, dass Gravitationswellen erstens relativ schwach sind, wenn man sie von normalen Objekten abstrahlen lässt. Und wann dann noch dazu kommt, dass sie sich auch nur sehr, sehr schwach auswirken. Und das hat Einstein zu der Vermutung veranlasst, dass es also praktisch die Wellen können zwar existieren, aber die wird man nicht detektieren können.
Bevor wir die Wellen versuchen zu detektieren, was ich noch versuche zu verstehen. Bei Licht hat man so die Vorstellung, ok, Lampe ist an, dann kommt Licht, Lampe ist aus, da kommt dann kein Licht vor. Gravitationswellen sollen jetzt sozusagen die Ausbreitung von Massen sein, also die Schwerkraft, die sie auswirken. Aber es hängt auch mit der Beschleunigung zusammen. Also Gravitation ist immer da, aber nur, wenn die Masse auch beschleunigt wird.
Genau, das ist aber nicht ganz analog zu dem, was wir aus der Elektrizität und dem Licht kennen. Wenn man genau hinschaut, also auf atomarer Ebene in den Glühwändel der inzwischen verbotenen Glühbirne, da werden Ladungsträger, Elektronen beschleunigt. Und die strahlen Licht ab oder der Fernsehsender oder das kleine Gerät, auf das man draufdrückt, damit das Garagentor endlich aufgeht. Dort ist ein kleiner Sender drin und das ist ein Stückchen Draht, durch die Elektronen hin und her fließen. Und dieses hin und her fließen ist eine Beschleunigung. Und dadurch senden die Elektronen elektromagnetische Wellen, Radiowellen oder wenn man das schnell genug macht, halt auch Licht ab. Das ist ungefähr das Gleiche. Wenn du jetzt sagst, Lampe an, Lampe aus, das ist jetzt nur ein Extrem. Da haben viele Ingenieure ganz lange dran gearbeitet, dass die Elektronen sich gerade passend bewegen, wenn du auf den Schalter drückst. Das können wir mit der Gravitation zurzeit nicht. Also natürlich können wir eine Maschine bauen, die Massen beschleunigt, also ganz einfach ein Schwungrad mit Gewichten an und rein und dann tritt man die Pedale und dann dreht sich das. Das Ding sendet Gravitationswellen aus, aber die sind viel zu schwach. Davon hat man nichts. Also da Lampe an, Lampe aus, da sieht man nichts. Und das ist ja ohnehin das Problem mit den Gravitationswellen, dass die halt extrem schwierig zu erzeugen sind. Man braucht große Massen, die sich schnell bewegen, deren Bewegung sich schnell ändert. Und man braucht extrem empfindliche Detektoren, eben weil die Gravitation so schwach ist.
Ich bin auch nicht bereit, das Feld schon zu räumen. Um das gut zu verstehen, also auch bei Licht ist es eigentlich so, dass es erst in dem Moment erzeugt wird, wo eine Bewegung vorliegt. Und wenn ich mir jetzt eine große Masse vorstelle, ein großer 1 km mal 1 km schwarzer Würfel von Schwermzeug, was es auch immer sein mag, kann das im Raum sein, ohne sich zu bewegen? Kann man sich etwas vorstellen, was sich nicht bewegt?
Wenn man mal von irgendwelchen Subabt oder Bewegung auf Atomhara-Skala durch Temperatur mal absieht, also wenn man sagt, wir machen das Ding auch mal kalt genug, dass die Atome sich nicht bewegen, klar.
Das ist dann keine Schwerkraft?
Doch, doch, das ist der Unterschied. Auch die Analogie wieder. Ein Elektron hat immer eine Ladung, ob du das bewegst oder nicht. Und zwei Elektronen stoßen sich immer ab, weil sie haben die gleiche Ladung. Ob die sich bewegen oder nicht. Aber sie strahlen nur Licht ab, wenn sie beschleunigt sind. Also auch dieser große, schwarze, fette, schwere Würfel, der da einfach im All sitzt wie so ein Borg-Cube und sich nicht bewegt, natürlich hat er Gravitation. Aber er strahlt erst dann Gravitationswellen ab, wenn er sich beschleunigt bewegt, in der Tat.
Also heißt, die Gravitationswellen sind nicht die sich ausbreitende Schwerkraft?
Korrekt. Gravitationswellen machen dich nicht schwerer oder leichter.
Aber wie breitet sich denn nun die Gravitation aus? Ich weiß, das weiß man nicht.
Man kann sich natürlich die Gleichung hinschreiben und man kann sich überlegen, was passiert. Und die gängigste Vorstellung, wenn man schon dieses Bild des Gummiuniversums, also dieses Gummituchs, in deren Mitte dann vielleicht eine schwere Masse liegt, und dass das so krümmt. Und jetzt kann man sich ja mal vorstellen, dass diese Masse, die da in der Mitte liegt, sich bewegt. Hin und her bewegt. Und dann sieht man natürlich auf dem Gummituch, wenn das Gummituch groß genug ist und man genau genug hinschaut, sieht man natürlich so wellenförmige Störungen weglaufen. Und das ist zum Beispiel eine Visualisierung, die eigentlich ganz nett ist, weil da nimmt man was, was man schon hat, nämlich das Gummituchuniversum, und modifiziert das ein bisschen.
Ja, aber das sind die Wellen.
Das sind die Wellen.
Aber die Gravitation selbst, also wie breitet sich dieses krümmende Ding?
Das krümmende Ding breitet sich. Die Gefahr ist, dass man hier zwei Bilder mischt. Und zwar die Gravitation, die Krümmung, das ist eigentlich von vornherein ein statisches Bild. Statisch heißt einfach, da ändert sich in der Zeit nichts. An der Stelle wird es dann gefährlich zu fragen, aber wie ist denn das da hingekommen? Weil das impliziert ja schon, dass sich irgendwann mal was geändert haben muss. Auf der anderen Seite habe ich Gravitationswellen, das ist ein rein dynamisches. Es gibt keine im Raum festgefrorenen Gravitationswellen, die bewegen sich immer mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit, so wie sich Licht auch immer mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit ausbreitet. Und wenn man jetzt verstehen will, was passiert zum Beispiel, wenn die Sonne verschwindet, dann muss man sich genau überlegen, wie zum Beispiel würde man das machen. Also angenommen irgendeine außerirdische Zivilisation würde einen großen Antrieb an unsere Sonne dranflanschen und den Countdown anleiten und dann innerhalb weniger Sekunden die Sonne aus dem Sonnensystem heraus schießen. Was würde dann passieren? Was würde man dann sehen? Auf der einen Seite würde man natürlich eine sich bewegende Sonne sehen, die sich relativ schnell entfernt. Und die hätte auch nach wie vor ihr Gravitationspotenzial. Aber in dem Moment, wo man die rausreißt, werden auch kleine Rippel Gravitationswellen entstehen durch diese beschleunigte Bewegung. Und das Ganze muss man im Gesamtzusammenhang sehen. Das heißt, wir können nicht einfach hingehen und sagen, wie breitet sich die Raum-, wie breitet sich die Schwerkraft aus? Die Schwerkraft ist dort. Und wenn ich jetzt etwas ändern will, wenn ich zum Beispiel die Sonne schwerer machen will oder leichter oder einfach wegnehmen will, dann muss ich mir überlegen, wie sich die Störung dann ausbreitet. Und diese Störung, die würden sich auch mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit ausbreiten, weil diese Störung kann ich immer als sehr komplizierte und sehr aufwendige, aber immerhin als Überlagerung von Gravitationswellen verstehen. Zumindest bis zu einem gewissen Punkt. Und damit hat man dann eigentlich so in der Vorstellung keine großen, oder ich jedenfalls, keine großen Probleme mehr. Da weiß man halt, wenn da irgendeine Störung ist, die breitet sich halt mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit aus. Das heißt, wenn die Sonne verschwinden würde, acht Minuten später wird's dunkel und wir werden von der Sonne nicht mehr angezogen.
Jetzt bin ich aber immer noch nicht so richtig, jetzt hab ich immer noch kein Bild im Kopf, was die Schwerkraft jetzt macht, ganz unabhängig von den Wellen. Gab's da nicht auch so ein vermutetes Elementarteilchen, das Graviton, oder ist das nur so eine theoretische Idee?
Nein, das Graviton ist eigentlich etwas, wo man sagt, wir treiben die Analogie zum Licht mal noch ein Stückchen weiter. Wir wissen, es gibt so etwas wie Elementarteilchen des Lichts, die sogenannten Photonen, und im Übrigen auch eine der Entdeckungen von Einstein außerhalb der Gravitation. Aber diese Photonen sind mathematische Objekte, mit denen ich das Licht auch dann noch beschreiben kann, wenn das Licht sehr schwach ist, oder ich Effekte beobachten möchte, wo ich genaue Mengen Energie brauche von dem Licht. Und da kann man sagen, naja, wenn ich jetzt ohnehin schon die Analogie zwischen Schwerkraft und elektromagnetischer oder elektrostatischer Anziehung Licht und Gravitationswellen habe, dann gehe ich doch gleich mal noch einen Schritt weiter. Das Licht hat Gravit, hat Photon, dann nenne ich das Teilchen, aus dem ich Gravitationswellen zusammensetze, mal Graviton. Bis dahin sind das Worte und nicht mehr. Jetzt kann man sich überlegen, was hat ein Graviton für Eigenschaften? Und da kommt man dann relativ schnell zu dem Schluss, dass man, um einen Graviton sinnvoll definieren zu können, dass das mehr ist als ein Wort, dazu brauche ich dann eine Quantentheorie der Gravitation. Die haben wir nicht. Also jedenfalls meines Wissens nicht. Vielleicht gibt es drei, der für Leute auf der Welt, die einen im Kopf haben, die halbwegs gut funktioniert. Aber vor allem haben wir keine testbare Theorie der Quanten-Gravitation. Wir haben keine Theorie, die Vorhersagen macht, die wir mit ins Labor nehmen können und sagen, jetzt mache ich mal ein Experiment und gucke nach, ob das so stimmt. Weil alle Effekte einer Quanten-Gravitation finden, also bisher vorhergesagten Effekte finden auf Energieskalen statt, die einfach menschlich experimentieren, bis auf weiteres nicht zugänglich sind. Und da kann man sich jetzt natürlich hinstellen und sagen, na, das ist mir aber egal, ich möchte die Analogie weiter treiben. Und dann kann ich sagen, ja, ich habe also so Gravitationswellen, das ist halt ein gigantischer Strom von Gravitonen. So wie ein Laserlicht auch ein ziemlich heftiger Strom von Photonen ist, dann kann man sich das bei Gravitationswellen genauso vorstellen. Ob das jetzt hilft beim Verständnis, weiß ich nicht. Aber gut, man kann die Analogie so weitertreiben. Und man macht schon deswegen, wenn man mit den Gravitonen keine echte Vorhersage treffen kann, die sich von normalen klassischen Wellen unterscheiden. Man macht da keine Fehler.
Okay, jetzt nehmen wir also zur Kenntnis, Gravitation ist da, breitet sich aus. Und sie ist aber im Verhältnis zu allen anderen Kräften, die wir so im Universum gewohnt sind, relativ schwach. Man stellt sich das ja immer stark vor, weil es tut ja auch weh, wenn man hinfällt. Aber wenn man sich anschaut, wie wenig Energie erforderlich ist, um einen Tennisball davon abzuhalten, auf den Boden zu fallen, ist es ja relativ schwach.
Und vor allem möchtest du nicht in der Situation sein, einen positiv geladenen Tennisball, also eine Ladung, die seiner Masse entspricht, von einer negativ geladenen Erde aufheben zu müssen. Das geht nämlich nicht. Also die Anziehung ist viel zu groß. Wenn es elektromagnetische Sachen sind, also die elektrische Anziehungskraft ist da sehr viel stärker als die Gravitation. Aber Gravitation ist sehr schwach. Wir merken die nur, weil wir eine enorme Gravitationsladung, in Anführungszeichen, die heißt unter Normalbürgern Masse, die haben wir halt um uns herum, das ist die Erde. Die hat richtig viel Masse. Deswegen haben wir eine Erdanziehungskraft, die wir auch spüren können. Die Anziehungskraft zwischen zwei Tennisbällen zum Beispiel, die Gravitationskraft 20.
So, und obwohl eine Masse in Bewegung der Theorie nach, nach der Theorie von Albert Einstein, im Prinzip Wellen erzeugen muss, sind die dann aber auch nochmal sehr schwach, weil schon die Kraft an sich sehr schwach ist und diese Sonderausprägung bei besonderer Beschleunigung ist halt nochmal viel schwächer. Aber es müsste sie eigentlich geben. Das ist das, was im Prinzip Albert Einstein gesagt hat. Und das bedeutet wiederum, dass man einerseits sehr, sehr, sehr feine Instrumente bräuchte, um das zu messen. Und andererseits extreme Beschleunigung als Ereignis vorfinden muss, um überhaupt davon ein Ergebnis abbekommen zu können.
Ja, man braucht halt das, was man eigentlich immer macht, wenn ein Signal sehr schwach ist. Man macht es lauter. In diesem Falle muss man halt nach Massen schauen, die sehr viel größer sind als das, was wir normalerweise in der Lage sind, zu bewegen. Und der erste, sagen wir mal, Nachweis von Gravitationswellen, obwohl der eigentlich eher indirekt war, aber immerhin, den kennen wir eigentlich schon aus den 70er Jahren, als nämlich die Leute mehr und mehr Pulsare entdeckt haben und dann eines Tages auch einen sogenannten Doppelpulsar, also zwei Neutronensterne, die Radiowellen, sehr gebündelte Radiowellen aussenden und die wir sehr genau messen können. Und da hat man halt festgestellt, wenn man dieses Doppelpulsarsystem lange genug beobachtet, dann stellt man fest, dass das Energie verliert. Und in der Gravitationstheorie, egal in welcher, ist das so ein bisschen, sagen wir mal, überraschend für jemanden, der das nicht gewohnt ist. Aber Dinge, die Energie verlieren, werden schneller. Also wenn im Auto Energie verliert, wirst du langsamer, wenn du auf die Bremse tritt. Wenn man im Orbit ist und Energie verliert, dann wird man schneller. Und der Effekt des Energieverlusts dieser Doppelpulsare ist, dass das regelmäßige Ticken, das man sieht, wenn der Radiostrahl des Pulsars über die Erde streicht, die Abstände des Ticks werden halt immer kleiner. Weil man weiß, die Spiralen um sich herum.
Also bei Neutronensteinen sind die extrem dichte, kleine, in sich zusammengefallene Sterne.
Genau, die wiegen ungefähr so viel wie eine Sonne. Und haben Durchmesser von 10 Kilometern. Und die haben ein starkes Magnetfeld. Und wenn da Materie drauf fällt, dann freilt die unten auf und das wird so heiß, dass das Radiowellen und Röntgenstrahlen alles Mögliche absendet. Aber man sieht halt Radiowellen.
Deswegen sind das diese Leuchttürme?
Das sind diese Leuchttürme, genau. Und diese Leuchttürme, die sieht man halt, die Frequenz, mit der die Leuchttürme blinken, die wird halt immer schneller. Und dann kann man sich ausrechnen, weil man die Massen relativ gut kennt, man kennt den Abstand relativ gut, kann man sich halt ausrechnen, was passiert denn, was wäre denn eine Möglichkeit, das abzustrahlen und guckt man nach, welchen Anteil könnten Gravitationswellen daran haben, und dann sieht man, das sind 100%. Also die Vorhersage der Gravitationswellenabstrahlung mit der beobachteten Abstrahlung, das passt bis auf 0,1% genau. Und seitdem weiß man eigentlich, die meisten Leute waren davon überzeugt, dass es die Gravitationswellen gibt, obwohl Einstein gesagt hat, wir werden die nie so recht messen können. Aber Einstein kannte auch noch keine Pulsare und keine Neutronensterne. Das sind alles Erkenntnisse, die in den letzten 100 Jahren dazugekommen sind. Und von diesen Doppelpulsaren, die genaue Zahl, die wir zurzeit beobachten, nicht, aber es ist so ein halbes Dutzend oder sowas. Da wussten wir eigentlich, wie gesagt, seit den 70er Jahren, waren wir uns relativ sicher, die meisten Wissenschaftler relativ sicher, die Dinger existieren, die Gravitationswellen. Und jetzt ist halt die Frage, wenn wir Objekte haben, die wir bereits kennen, die irgendwelche Wellen abstrahlen, können wir ein Instrument bauen, das auch Wellen detektieren kann von Objekten, die wir noch nicht kennen. Das ist ja ein Unterschied, ob da ein Leuchtturm vor sich hin blinkt und man feststellt, das Blinken des Leuchtturms wird immer schneller. Oder ob man auch die Insel neben dem Leuchtturm sieht, die gerade mal keinen Leuchtturm hat, aber wo vielleicht auch irgendwas leise vor sich hin blinkt. Das war eigentlich sozusagen, hat der Gravitationswellensuche noch mal so ein bisschen den Schub gegeben Mitte der 70er. Die ersten Versuche, Gravitationswellen zu detektieren, kommen aus den 60ern. Der Joseph Weber an der Universität von Maryland in den USA, der hat sich halt überlegt, wenn so eine Gravitationswelle kommt und im Prinzip auf eine Glocke trifft, dann müsste diese Glocke ja wie durch einen Klöppel angeschlagen anfangen zu schwingen. Na gut, er hat natürlich keine Glocke genommen, sondern einen Aluminiumblock. Und das mit dem Anfang zu schwingen, das muss man sich auch nicht so vorstellen, dass das dann richtig gong macht, weil es in Deutschland immer noch sehr kleine Signale gibt. Und so hat das halt angefangen. Leider hat der Joe Weber dann ein Signal gesehen, das sich letztlich als falsch herausgestellt hat. Das war ein Ausreißer, vermutlich, was er da gesehen hat. Aber das hat zumindest dazu geführt, als er gesagt hat, ich habe eine gefunden, dass mehrere Gruppen auf der Welt gesagt haben, na ja, komm, dann bauen wir uns auch mal so ein Ding. So schwierig ist das nicht. Das musst du dir so vorstellen, die Aluminiumzylinder, die waren alle so, ja, vielleicht so 2 Meter lang und 50 Zentimeter Durchmesser. Und dann haben die Leute angefangen zu sagen, bei Zimmertemperatur wird das alles nichts. Das müssen wir auf die Temperatur von flüssigem Helium runterkühlen. Es wurde also relativ schnell von einem, ich werde nicht sagen mal, eben an einem Nachmittag aufgebaut, aber aus einem relativ einfachen Experiment sind extrem aufwändige Experimente geworden.
Aber was wollte man denn mit dieser Aluminiumröhre jetzt genau messen?
Die hätte man zur Detektion verwendet und gesagt hat, wenn eine kommt, dann fängt die an zu schwingen. Und dann haben wir da im Prinzip kleine Mikrofone dran, also Umwandler von mechanischer Schwingung in elektrische Signale. Und dann kann man sich das angucken. Und wie eine Antenne, wie ein Richtmikrofon, ist, dass die Antenne in bestimmte Richtungen stärker empfindlich als eine andere.
Und die Schwingung wollte man im Aluminium oder von dem Aluminium eingeschlossenen?
Nein, im Aluminium. Das ist keine Röhre, das ist ein Zylinder. Also vollständiger? Vollständiger, so anderthalb Tonnen Aluminium. Und gut, das hat sich dann letztlich herausgestellt, dass diese Experimente bis in die 90er hineingelaufen sind. Aber 1990, 1992 oder so, da hat sich dann aber letztlich herausgestellt, dass man mit diesen Experimenten bis zu einer gewissen Empfindlichkeit kommt, aber dann auch nicht mehr viel weiter. Und wenn man die Empfindlichkeit weiter hätte erhöhen wollen, das wäre von der Technologie her unrealistisch geworden. Man hätte viel mehr Aluminiummaterial gebraucht, man hätte viel mehr auf die Reinheit des Materials achten müssen. Das ist alles nicht, was man mal so eben macht.
Warum hat man denn überhaupt Aluminium genommen?
Da gibt es eine interessante Anekdote dazu. Wie bei allen Anekdoten weiß man nicht so ganz genau, ob das wahr ist. Aber als der Joe Weber sich das überlegt hat, hat er sich halt gesagt, er braucht jetzt hier irgendwas, was sozusagen als Glocke verwenden kann. Er hat sich in seinem Labor umgeschaut und festgestellt, er hat hier nichts. Und dann, die University of Maryland, ich will nicht sagen in Gehweite, nichts ist in Gehweite in den USA, aber ein kurzer Fahrt um die Eck, da sind die Naval Shipyards der US Navy, also die Werften. Und da ist er hingegangen und gefragt, sag mal, habt ihr nicht ein Stück Altmetall? Und da haben die gesagt, ja, hier guck mal, wir haben da so einen Aluminienzylinder, den wir nicht mehr brauchen. Das ist angeblich die Story, dass er genau diesen Aluminienzylinder genommen hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt. Vermutlich ist da ein bisschen mehr Gehirnschmalz in die Geometrie hineingeflossen. Aber das war jetzt keine Analyse mit Atomgewicht und Struktur oder sonst irgendwas, was das jetzt besonders gerade machen würde? Überhaupt gar nicht. Das ist dann später gekommen, dass die Leute versucht haben, die Legierung zu optimieren oder ein anderes Material zu nehmen. Die Leute haben dann zum Beispiel auch, es gibt einen Detektor aus Niobium, weil der es halt extrem gute Materialeigenschaften bei tiefen Temperaturen hat. Aber diese Analysen sind sehr viel später gekommen. Und man dann versucht hat, die Empfindlichkeit, auch die letzten Sachen der Empfindlichkeit, rauszuquetschen. Parallel dazu hat dann in den 70ern schon am Caltech haben die Leute angefangen, sich darüber Gedanken zu machen. Kann ich sowas nicht vielleicht auch nicht mit solchen unförmigen Aluminiumdingern messen, sondern vielleicht mit Lasern? Der Laser ist in den 60er Jahren, Anfang Mitte der 60er Jahre entwickelt worden. Mitte der 70er Jahre waren die Dinger so weit, dass man die in jedem Labor einsetzen konnte. Da konnte man hingehen, die kaufen. Und da haben die Leute gesagt, ist das nicht vielleicht auch eine Möglichkeit, das zu messen? Und da gibt es natürlich, wie immer, haben solche Sachen viele Väter. Der Bob Forward in Stanford und der Ray Weiss haben halt angefangen, diese Instrumente zu bauen. Und der Heinz Billing in Garching hat auch angefangen, solche Instrumente zu bauen, einfach um zu schauen, wie weit kann ich die Empfindlichkeit denn damit treiben. Und bei laserbasierten Instrumenten ist das dann der Effekt einer Gravitationswelle auf ein solches Instrument, ist immer, dass er die Länge des Instruments verändert. Und Längenänderungen kann ich mit Lasern extrem gut messen. Und die interessante Sache ist, dass die Längenänderung davon abhängt, wie groß das Instrument bereits ist. Das heißt, das ist direkt proportional zu der Länge der Strecke, die der Laser zu messen braucht. Das heißt, wenn ich ein 1 Meter großes Instrument habe und daneben ein Instrument baue, was ein Kilometer groß ist, dann hat das Instrument, was ein Kilometer groß ist, den tausendfachen Effekt. Und wenn meine Signale ohnehin schon sehr klein sind, dann ist natürlich die naheliegende Sache, bauen wir das Ding mal größer. Dann wird das Signal auch größer. So sind diese Prototypen von den ersten Sachen, die sozusagen noch auf einen ganz normalen S-Zimmertisch gepasst hätten, so vielleicht 1 Meter mal 1 Meter oder so was, über die ersten Prototypen in Garching zum Beispiel, ein 30 Meter Prototyp, in Glasgow ein 10 Meter Prototyp, also 10 Meter Armlänge oder 30 Meter Armlänge, sind dann zu zum Beispiel Geo 600, da haben wir 1200 Meter Armlänge, oder zu den großen Detektoren, den LIGO und Virgo Detektoren, mit 3 Kilometern Armlänge und 4 Kilometern Armlänge.
Das funktioniert aber im Prinzip genauso wie mein Abstandsmesser, den ich mir im Baumarkt kaufe?
Nein, der Abstandsmesser, den du im Baumarkt kaufst, der funktioniert im Prinzip so, dass der ein Licht aussendet und auf dieses Licht ein gewisses Muster drauf moduliert, also im Prinzip kann man sich überlegen, der macht das im gewissen Rhythmus heller und dunkler. Und dieses, wenn das auf die Wand auftrifft und dann der Fotodetektor innen, also der Detektor im Laser-Messgerät, der sieht dann in einer gewissen Zeit später das hell und dunkel aufflackern mit dem gleichen Rhythmus. Und dann dividiert er das einfach durch die Lichtgeschwindigkeit und dann sagt er, na jetzt ist das halt so weit weg.
Das heißt, man misst einfach die Laufzeit?
Man misst die Laufzeit, das machen wir eben. Gut, man kann das alles auch auf Laufzeit umrechnen, wenn man möchte, aber die für mich bessere Erklärung ist zu sagen, der Laser, die Gravitationswelle verändert den optischen Weg, den der Laser nimmt. Und wenn normalerweise, sagen wir mal, eine irrsinnig große Zahl von Wellenlängen in diese Strecke hineinpasst, wenn die Gravitationswelle kommt, passt halt dieselbe irrsinnig große Zahl plus ein klein bisschen rein. Oder minus ein ganz klein bisschen rein. Und diese Änderung der optischen Weglänge, die Phasenänderung des Lasers, die kann man extrem gut messen. Und das war eigentlich der Grundgedanke darum, warum nehmen wir nicht Licht dafür? Weil wir, war halt bekannt, dass man die relative Phasenlage von Licht extrem gut messen kann. Und noch besser kann man die Veränderung messen. Und alles, was wir messen, sind Veränderungen da in den Detektoren. Und das hat sich halt gezeigt, dass die Technologie, die man in den 70ern schon vor Augen hatte, sich tatsächlich auf eine Empfindlichkeit vorantreiben lässt, dass man damit dann tatsächlich auch Gravitationswellen detektieren kann.
Okay, also das Ziel, die Gravitationswellen zu detektieren, einfach um Einschein zu beweisen, aber vielleicht auch andere Erkenntnisse daraus zu ziehen, wurden jetzt verschiedene Wege verfolgt, aber das mit den Lasern erschien, recht früh ein guter Weg zu sein, weil man in gewisser Hinsicht die Empfindlichkeit allein schon durch längere Lichtstrecken ganz gut tunen kann und umso besser man auch in der Lage ist, den Unterschied in diesen Verschiebungen zu messen, umso feiner wird das Instrument. Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, da kommt jetzt eine Gravitationswelle oder wir warten auf diesen Moment, wo sie kommt. Die wirkt sich auf uns aus, wie das Gravitation auch tut, nur eben für einen sehr kurzen Moment wird sozusagen dieses Raumzeitgefüge, was ohnehin schon die ganze Zeit startet, mehr oder weniger statisch gekrümpft wird, wird für einen kurzen Moment nochmal so schnell durchgeschoben. Kann man das so sagen? Und das wirkt sozusagen darauf, dass unser Raum, in dem unser Licht läuft, in dem wir messen, kürzer und länger breiter wird oder so?
Also die Erklärung, die ich dazu manchmal gebe, ist, Gravitationswellen machen uns nicht schwerer oder leichter, aber sie machen uns breiter oder höher. Das heißt, was eine Gravitationswelle tut, ist, die erhöht nicht diese Krümmung, also die Schwerkraft oder macht uns nicht schwerer, sondern was sie macht, wenn du dir dieses Gummituch nochmal vorstellst, dieser schweren Murmel in der Mitte, die zieht die Murmel nicht weiter nach unten oder schiebt sie weiter nach oben, sondern die guckt sich das Gummituch an. Wenn man sich jetzt mal vorstellt, dass auf diesem Gummituch lauter kleine Kreise aufgemalt sind, dann nimmt die so einen Kreis und zieht den in die eine Richtung, ein bisschen die Länge und in der nächsten halben Länge staucht es. Das heißt, macht aus so einem Kreis eine Ellipse und dann die Ellipse in die andere Richtung. Also so eine Streck- und Quetschbewegung. Aber das macht niemanden schwerer oder leichter. Nicht mal, wenn man sagt, ach ja, aber die Effekte sind ganz klein. Das ist sozusagen ein Effekt, wenn man so möchte, in der anderen Richtung. Es ist nicht etwas, was einen schwerer macht, sondern es verändert Abstände. Und wenn man sich so einen Laser-Interferometer, wer da schon Bilder von den Leico-Detektoren gesehen hat, die sind ja in der letzten Zeit durch die Presse gegangen, das sind halt zwei lange, vier Kilometer lange Strecken, die im rechten Winkel zueinander stehen.
Das heißt, ihr eine misst sozusagen die Draussehnung in die andere?
Und wenn jetzt so eine Gravitationswelle genau senkrecht von oben käme, sagen wir mal, sich also senkrecht von oben ausbreiten würde, dann würde die für einen kurzen Moment den einen Arm etwas kürzer und den anderen Arm etwas länger machen. Und dann in der nächsten halben Wellenlänge das Ganze wieder andersrum. Also den einen länger und den anderen kürzer und dann wieder zurück und so, bis sie dann durch ist. Das heißt, die verändert periodisch die Armlänge des einen und des anderen Arm, so im Gegentakt, wenn sie richtig orientiert ist. Und das kann man natürlich sehr schön, wenn man die Empfindlichkeit hat, kann man das sehr schön messen. Man nimmt einfach die Differenz der beiden Armlängen und sagt, wenn die beiden sich geändert haben, die Summe bleibt die gleiche im Übrigen. Das heißt, man hat eine schöne Möglichkeit zu überprüfen, ob man da hier völlig misst oder nicht. Die Summe muss die gleiche bleiben, aber die Differenz verändert sich. Aber es macht nichts in dem Direktor schwerer oder leichter. Es ändert wirklich nur Abstände.
Jetzt sind wir im Prinzip schon von den Gravitationswellen und wie man sie messen möchte, auch zu den konkreten Orten gekommen, die jetzt ja auch in den letzten Wochen so eine große Rolle gespielt haben. Ich fasse das nochmal kurz zusammen. Also Geo 600 war im Prinzip das Erste?
Nein, also Geo 600, das ist so eine gewisse Sache. Als Geo 600 angefangen hat, die ursprüngliche Planung war ein großer Detektor mit drei Kilometern Armlänge, so wie auch vergleichbar mit LIGO oder Virgo. Da ist dann aber 1990 ein anderes weltpolitisches Ereignis dazwischen gekommen und die Prioritäten hatten sich einfach geändert. Und dann ist es den Leuten gelungen, die Geldgeber davon zu überzeugen, dass man doch wenigstens eine kleinere Version baut, sozusagen zwischen den 30 Meter Prototypen, die wir jetzt schon hatten, und den kilometergroßen Detektoren. Und die erste Idee war 300 Meter, dass man einfach mal Sachen ausprobieren kann, die man in kleineren Laboren nicht ausprobieren kann, weil sie einfach noch keine Rolle spielen. Es gibt dann immer irgendwelche Rauscheffekte, die erst auftreten, wenn man es ein bisschen größer macht. Das weiß man blöderweise vorher nicht, deswegen möchte man das gern schrittweise ausprobieren. Als man sich darauf geeinigt hatte, das Geld ist da, hat man sich das Land angeguckt und gesagt, da passen auch 600 Meter hin. Das Teure sind die Endstücke und nicht das Rohr dazwischen. Dann kann man auch 600 Meter machen. Dann ist man auf die Idee gekommen, dass man das Licht einmal falten kann in den Armen. Letztendlich sind es 1200 Meter. Das sind dann Details. Das ist aber auch Anfang der 90er gewesen. Das ist ungefähr die gleiche Zeit, zu der die Planung und die Finanzierung für LIGO angelaufen ist. Es war also von vornherein klar, dass die beiden Sachen miteinander sozusagen in Koexistenz da sein werden. Es war auch von vornherein klar, dass der Geodetektor letztendlich die endgültige Empfindlichkeit mit den großen Detektoren nicht mithalten kann, einfach weil die Arme zu kurz sind. Aber es hat halt über Jahre hinweg, weil es halt ein kleinerer Detektor war, war es deutlich einfacher, mal eben, in Anführungsstrichen, was auszuprobieren. Wenn man sich überlegt, dass man ein Vakuumsystem hat, wo die Röhren 1,20 Meter Durchmesser haben und vier Kilometer lang sind, da ist man etwas zögerlicher fundamental, was dran zu ändern, wenn man sagt, ach, warum machen wir das nicht mal eben so? Na ja, weil das halt, ja, das muss man wieder auspumpen und hier und da. Und das ist mit einem kleineren Detektor alles ein bisschen einfacher, schneller und unkomplizierter. Und der Geo 600 hat über Jahre hinweg ganz hervorragende Arbeit im Bereich dieser Sachen. Lass uns das doch mal ausprobieren, ob das denn funktioniert. Wenn man festgeht, das funktioniert aber ganz hervorragend, dann lass uns das doch auch mal den großen Detektoren mal in Angriff nehmen.
Also Geo 600 war im Prinzip auch so ein bisschen der Ort für die technologischen Prototypen und dort ist eigentlich die Detektortechnik als solche vorangetrieben worden.
Da wurde ganz viel vorangetrieben, ganz viel Sachen, die zum Beispiel im Bereich der Spiegelaufhängungen, um die von der Untergrundbewegung zu entkoppeln, die sind im Rahmen bei Geo 600 mal ausprobiert worden. Und dann hat man festgestellt, das funktioniert aber ganz hervorragend. Und dann macht man das dann auch in der nächsten Ausbaustufe den großen Detektoren. Also das als Technologiedemonstrator sozusagen oder als Technologieprototyp lange Jahre extrem gute Dienste geleistet. Und man darf nicht vergessen, Geo 600 hat auch lange Jahre, also bis jetzt zu den Advanced-Lago-Geschichten, zumindest einen kleinen Beitrag geleistet in der Familie der Detektoren. Weil gut, selbst wenn man nur ein Faktor 5 weniger empfindlich ist oder so, dann hat man halt nur einen etwas kleineren Beitrag. Wenn jetzt die Signale von den verschiedenen Detektoren zusammengenommen werden, gemittelt werden und geguckt, ob da wirklich was ist, dann gibt man den kleinen Detektoren etwas weniger Gewicht, weil die ja nicht so genau messen können. Aber die Empfindlichkeit war doch lange Jahre so gut, dass man da guten Gewissens sagen konnte. Also, die sind Teil der großen Familie. Jetzt mit den großen Detektoren in der Ausbaustufe, in der LIGO und Virgo, oder jedenfalls LIGO jetzt ist, ist man mit kleinen Detektoren nicht mehr so richtig konkurrenzfähig.
Dann kommen wir noch mal kurz jetzt zu dem Ereignis, was wir ja schon eingangs erwähnt hatten und von dem die meisten sicherlich jetzt auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise schon gehört haben. Ist ja jetzt auch ein kleines Märchen, muss ich sagen, weil wie irre ist denn das bitte? Da ist dann quasi die existierende Messtechnologie ausgetauscht worden. Ich glaube, um Faktor 10 konnten bessere Messergebnisse erzielt werden als vorher. Kann man vielleicht gleich nochmal sagen, was das auch ausgemacht hat. Und einen Tag später wird schon ein Signal empfangen, was alle anstarren und sagen, da will uns doch jetzt einer irgendwie, das will uns doch jetzt einer einen Streich spielen.
Also wir haben vorher ja jahrelang während der ganzen Ausbaustufen und auch in den Antragsphasen für Weltraumgestützendetektoren und so eine zentrale Botschaft, die wir immer versucht haben zu vermitteln, ist in dem Moment, wo wir einen solchen Detektor mit der richtigen Empfindlichkeit anschalten, da werden wir was sehen, was wir vorher nicht erwarten. Das war bisher immer so, in dem Moment, wo man einen neuen Nachweiskanal hat, findet man Dinge, die man vorher nicht kannte.
Weil irgendein neues Rauschverhalten auftritt oder so?
Weil irgendwas Neues da ist, was man vorher einfach nicht wusste, dass es da ist, wenn man es nicht gesehen hat. Das war mit den Röntgenstrahlensatelliten schon so, als der erste, die kann man von der Erde nicht beobachten, die Atmosphäre absorbiert alles, das heißt, man braucht was im Weltall. Als Rosat gestartet war, hat man halt auf einmal Dinge gesehen, da war einem überhaupt nicht klar, dass davon so viele kippt. Und das ist jetzt hier im Prinzip genau das Gleiche. Dass man so einen Detektor anschaltet, oder wenn man sich das genau anguckt, im Prinzip noch nicht mal angeschaltet hatte. Und man sieht bereits ein Signal.
Also nicht angeschaltet, weil er im Prinzip eigentlich offiziell noch im Testlauf war.
Ja, genau. Aber der Übergang von der Testphase zur Messphase war eher ein So. Und jetzt sind wir in der Messphase. Da wurde nicht ein rotes Band durchgeschnitten oder der Detektor einmal außen wieder eingeschaltet. Sondern da hat man einfach gesagt, Jungs, lasst mal die Finger von den Knöpfen. Jetzt wollen wir mal richtig messen. Und das ist auf der einen Seite, kann man sagen, haben wir euch doch gesagt, oder? Genauso wird das kommen. Auf der anderen Seite ist das natürlich schon ein ziemlicher Knaller. Dass man vielleicht innerhalb des ersten Jahres mal was sieht, damit hat eigentlich jeder gerechnet. Dass man in der ersten Woche was sieht, da muss man schon entweder sehr viel Glück haben, oder von solchen Systemen sind so viele da draußen, dass man einfach gar nicht anders kann. Also das ist so die Sache, wenn man irgendwo durch den dunklen Wald geht und einen Bekannten trifft, dann hat man entweder ganz viel Glück, oder man hat vergessen, dass man auf dem Klassenausflug ist. Und da laufen noch 20 oder 30 von den Jungs rum. Und ja, das ist schon sehr beeindruckend. Und weil du das vorhin sagtest, auch 100 Jahre nach Einstein, und jetzt haben wir Einstein tatsächlich bewiesen, dass er recht hatte, das ist schon ganz schön viel mehr als nur das. Also das ist so ein bisschen so, das ist ja was, was wir noch nie vorher gesehen haben. Man liest dann häufig, ich hab auch auf Facebook und auf anderen Blogs Sachen gelesen und gesagt haben, ja, das ist so ein bisschen vergleichbar mit dem, dass Galileo dann vor 405 Jahren, 406 Jahren, 7, was auch immer, aber jedenfalls vor mehr als 400 Jahren sein Teleskop genommen hat und die Jupiter-Monde entdeckt hat. Aber das stimmt nicht. Die Menschen haben schon immer an den Himmel geguckt. Jupiter war schon immer zu sehen mit dem bloßen Auge. Der Mond war immer zu sehen mit dem bloßen Auge, die Sterne sind mit bloßem Auge zu sehen. Das heißt, jeder wusste, da war was. Da guckt man halt, wenn man das Instrument hat, mal ein bisschen genauer hin und natürlich findet man dann ganz viel mehr interessante Sachen. Aber das ist so ein bisschen, wir haben vorher noch nichts gesehen, gar nichts. Wir wussten nicht, jedenfalls nicht so, dass wir das hätten beweisen können, dass solche Objekte mit, sagen wir mal, 20, 30 Sonnenmassen, schwarze Löcher in Paaren vorkommen. Und die dann uns auch noch den Gefallen tun, zur richtigen Zeit dann zu verschmelzen und Gravitationswellen abzusenden. Ich dachte, entweder wir sind extrem glücklich, extrem glücklich, dass wir das gesehen haben und davon gibt es nur eine Handvoll im Universum und das nächste Mal passiert das in 5000 Jahren. Oder das Universum ist voll von den Dingern, die wir bisher noch nicht gesehen haben. Und mal ganz ehrlich, ich glaube ja ein bisschen an Glück, aber nicht an so viel Glück. Also da werden schon eine ganze Menge von den Systemen da draußen sein, von denen wir bisher nichts wissen. Sonst hätten wir sie nicht so früh gesehen.
Wie ist denn das gelaufen? Also ich würde ja mal vermuten, also die Messung war am 14. September 2015, wichtig. Also ein Tag, nachdem die neue Technik eingeschaltet wurde. Und dann haben das zuerst ja glaube ich zwei Leute in Hannover entdeckt, weil die sozusagen die ersten waren, die wach waren.
Genau, ich wollte gerade sagen, vermutlich hat die Zeitverschiebung eine Rolle gespielt.
So und aufgefallen ist ja sozusagen nur, dass eine Software gesagt hat, okay wir empfangen ja hier die ganze Zeit Daten, aber hier sind jetzt Ausschläge, die sind über einem normalen Rauschen, wie wir das bisher definiert haben. Schaut euch das mal genauer an. So und dann guckt man sich das an und dann?
Dann guckt man vermutlich erstmal ziemlich dumm, weil also eine Sache, die dieses Signal auszeichnet, ist, dass ich glaube mit einem solchen Signal in der Stärke vorher niemand gerechnet hat. Also jeder oder ganz viele Leute, ich will nicht sagen jeder, aber ganz viele Leute sind sicher davon ausgegangen, dass das erste, was so ein Detektor sehen wird, die es verschmelzt zwei Neutronensterne ist. Weil einfach wir wissen, dass die Dinge existieren über die Pulsare, wir wissen, dass es unabwendbar ist, dass die Führer da später miteinander verschmelzen, weil die Energie verlieren durch Gravitationswellenabstrahlung. Das heißt, da kann man sich ausrechnen, wie häufig das passiert. Und dann weiß man, das ist ein Effekt, eine Quelle, die passiert häufig, die strahlt häufig genug ab, die wird man dann irgendwann zum Detektor sehen. Deren Signalstärke ist aber deutlich kleiner. Das heißt, da braucht man sehr viel Datenanalyse und man muss sehr viele Signale miteinander vergleichen. Und die sogenannten Housekeeping-Signale, also die ganzen Signale, die irgendwelche Diagnosesensoren am Detektor mit auswerten, dass da nicht gerade ein Hase übers Rohr gelaufen ist oder was auch immer. Und dass das jetzt, wenn man sich die Rohdaten anschaut, die sind ja veröffentlicht, das ist ein Signal, das sieht man mit dem bloßen Auge im Datenstrom. Und ich glaube, wenn ich das gesehen hätte, meine erste Reaktion wäre gesagt, da will mich jemand veralbern. Weil das ist nichts, was man erwartet. Und gut, aber wenn es denn da ist, dann muss man sich halt überlegen, so und jetzt. Und ich denke mal, dass was dann als nächstes passiert ist, ich war ja auch nicht dabei, aber was als nächstes passiert ist, dass man den Leuten halt gesagt hat, so okay, hier ist ein Signal. Rechnet mal aus, was denn eine mögliche Quelle dafür ist. Und da weiß man, wenn man sich das anguckt, das sieht aus wie zwei schwarze Löcher, die miteinander verschmelzen. Also, Jungs, rechnet. Das sieht man in der Signalform.
Also man hat das schon mal ausgerechnet?
Ja, man hat vorher bereits ausgerechnet, dass es einer der, sagen wir mal, Durchbrüche, die in den letzten 10, 15 Jahren passiert sind. Also 2005, wenn nicht 2005, 2006 hat man es zum ersten Mal geschafft, eine Verschmelzung der letzten paar Orbits zweier Schwarzer Löcher umeinander zu berechnen und die Wellen auszurechnen. Das war ein extremer Durchbruch im Bereich der sogenannten numerischen Relativität, weil das immer so war. Die Gleichung, zwar sind es weit 100 Jahre bekannt, also da kann man sich ja denken, so viel falsch kann man da nicht machen, aber es hängt halt extrem von der Implementierung des Computercodes ab. Und bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, bis die Leute den Trick gefunden hatten, wie man das vernünftig ausrechnet, waren halt die beiden Möglichkeiten, entweder dass der Rechner oder das Computerprogramm stürzt ab, oder man weiß halt, es braucht 1000 Jahre, um bis zum Ergebnis zu kommen, dann hat es auch keinen Sinn mehr. Und das ist also einer der Durchbrüche gewesen, 2005. Das ist eine interessante Frage. In diesem Falle weiß man das, weil zwei Gruppen unabhängig voneinander, das ist auch so eine Geschichte, wo man sagt, das kann eigentlich nicht sein, aber innerhalb von einem Monat zwei Gruppen unabhängig voneinander auf verschiedenen Wegen zu dem Ergebnis gekommen sind.
Das heißt, es gab nicht nur eine Implementierung?
Nein, es gab zwei Implementierungen, zwei, die auch tatsächlich vom Algorithmus her vollständig verschieden waren. Und zwischen den beiden Gruppen hat es zwar ein bisschen Interaktion gegeben, also man ist ja nicht ganz still und sagt, ich sag dir nicht, was ich hier tue, aber es war halt doch so, dass die andere Gruppe gesagt hat, ne, also das, was ihr da macht, das funktioniert, ne, aber ich mach lieber das. Und die andere Gruppe gesagt, ne, ne, ne, ich mach lieber das. Und dann wirklich innerhalb von einem Monat Abstand die beiden Veröffentlichungen rausgekommen sind, die dann auch im Ergebnis miteinander übereingestimmt haben. Und das ist so was, wo man sagt, das gibt einem ein bisschen, sagen wir mal, Gewissheit, dass dort, dass das nicht kompletter Blödsinn ist, was dort ausgerechnet ist.
Und das Ergebnis ist im Prinzip eine Vorhersage für die Art und Weise, wie eine solche Gravitationswelle in ihrer Struktur ist. Und in dem Moment, wo man dann etwas empfängt, kann man diese Struktur in dem Gemessenen vielleicht erkennen.
Die Vorhersage geht tatsächlich noch ein Stückchen weiter. Man kann präzise ausrechnen, wie so ein Signal im Detektor aussieht. Also man gibt sich zwei schwarze Löcher mit Massen und Drehimpulsausrichtung und einem Pipa-Pofor vor und dreht an der Kurbel und herausfällt eine Zeitserie, die aussieht, wie so das muss der Detektor messen.
Aber man weiß ja jetzt gar nicht, was für Massen da...
Doch, das weiß man in der Zwischenzeit schon. Also die Signale, gibt es zwei Effekte, die Frequenz, mit der diese Welle ankommt, hängt von den Massen ab. Und zwar nur von den Massen. Und die Amplitude, also wie laut das Signal war, hängt von den Massen und der Entfernung ab. Und zwar nur von den Massen und der Entfernung. Das ist anders als in der Astronomie, wo es ein entsetzlich schwieriges Problem ist, die Helligkeit eines Sterns genau zu bestimmen. Weil was wir hier sehen, ist die scheinbare Helligkeit, also das, was in unseren Teleskopen ankommt. Damit wissen wir noch nicht, wie hell der Stern war. Erstens wissen wir nicht so ganz genau, wie weit er weg ist. Jedenfalls für Sterne, die weiter entfernt sind als eine gewisse Entfernung. Und wir wissen auch nicht, was zwischendurch passiert mit dem Licht. Wenn da Staub im Weg ist, dann wird das Licht abgeschwächt. Dann sieht der Stern dunkler und roter aus, als er eigentlich ist. Und das ist ein relativ schwieriges Problem in der Astronomie, zu versuchen, diese Effekte genau auseinanderzurechnen und wirklich möglichst genau am Stern anzukommen mit der Helligkeit. Wie hell, wie viel Energie sendet dieser Stern aus und damit auch, wie alt ist er im Wesentlichen. Gravitationswellen, die scheren sich und den Staub nicht. Die breiten sich einfach aus.
Werden die schwächer, umso länger sie unterwegs sind?
Wie alle anderen Abstrahlungseffekte auch. Die Energie, die in so einer Gravitationswelle enthalten ist, die bleibt erhalten. Aber wenn die Kugelschale um die Quelle immer größer wird, dann weiß man, die Oberfläche der Kugel verhält sich wie das Quadrat des Radius. Und das heißt nichts anderes, als wenn durch jede Oberfläche die gleiche Energie muss. Dann gibt die Energie der Gravitationswelle, wie die Energie von Licht auch, verschwindet mit dem Abstandsquadrat.
Das heißt, umso weiter weg dieses Ereignis ist, umso schwächer ist es.
In einer doppelten Entfernung ist die Energie viermal geringer. Der Vorteil, den unsere Detektoren haben, alle unsere Detektoren, die interferometrischen Detektoren, wir detektieren nicht Energie, wir detektieren Amplitude. Das heißt, das Signal wird nicht mit dem Quadrat der Entfernung schwächer, sondern nur mit der einfachen Entfernung schwächer. Das heißt, das Signal, das doppelt so weit weg ist, hat nur noch die halbe Amplitude. Das hat einen großen Vorteil, weil nämlich die Amplitude nicht so schnell verschwindet wie die Energie. Das heißt, wir können weiter nach draußen schauen. Bei gleichen Energien sozusagen oder bei gleichen Detektion effizienzen können wir weiter in die Vergangenheit oder weiter zurückschauen oder weiter raus ins Universum.
Das heißt, wenn man sich das Signal anschaut, dann kann man der Frequenz ansehen, was für Massen da beteiligt waren.
Und aus der Amplitude kriegen wir raus, wie weit entfernt das ist.
Also aus dem Verlauf der...
Aus der Stärke einfach. Und aus der genauen Form des Signals, ob das nun so hoch geht oder nur so hoch geht oder ob da vielleicht noch zwischendurch noch mal so ein kleiner Wow drin ist oder sowas. Da kann man dann, wenn man sich das Signal genau anschaut, da lernt man dann auch darüber, wie die Drehimpulse der schwarzen Löcher... Also schwarze Löcher haben massen Drehimpuls. Die drehen sich, ja. Und die müssen sich ja nicht in die gleiche Richtung drehen, sondern die können, wenn man sich wie so ein Kreisel, also der Nordpol des schwarzen Loches, die beiden Nordpole der schwarzen Löcher, die müssen nicht in die gleiche Richtung zeigen, wenn die aufeinandertreffen. Die können irgendwie stehen. Das ist nicht wie bei Star Trek, wo die feindlichen Raumschiffe immer in der richtigen Orientierung auf dem Schirm sind. Sondern die können, also im Weltall können die irgendwie stehen. Und die relative Stellung dieser Drehimpulse, also wo der Nordpol hin zeigt, wie schnell die sich drehen, all das beeinflusst die Signalform. Und das kann man einfach modellieren und gucken, solange am Modell drehen, die Eingangsparameter ist das Modell, solange drehen, bis das Signal mit dem übereinstimmt, was ich im Detektor gesehen habe. Und dann kann man sich fragen, wie genau kann man das tun? Und das bei dem, was bei dem GW 1509-14 kommt man halt auf eine gewisse Genauigkeit, was die Massen angeht. Da weiß man, es waren 32 und 26 Sonnenmassen, plus minus ein bisschen.
Die Zahl bezieht sich jetzt auf?
Die schwarzen Löcher im Urzustand, also die beiden Konstituenten, die in dem doppelschwarzen Lochsystem vorhanden waren. Das eine hatte 32, glaube ich, Sonnenmassen, das andere 26 oder sowas.
Dieses GW 14, das ist sozusagen die Katalog.
Ach so, das ist die Telefonnummer, ja. Also, die werden irgendwelche Ereignisse in der Astronomie oder Radioastronomie oder Pulsar, werden also typischerweise mit einem Kürzel, in diesem Falle Gravitationswellen, GW deswegen, und dann dem Datum. Und wenn es halt mehrere gibt, kommt dahinter kleine Buchstaben A, B, C, D. Soweit sind wir noch nicht, dass wir mehrere pro Tag sehen, aber...
Okay, das heißt, man hat jetzt einfach dieses Signal gesehen, das war sehr stark, das war sehr überraschend. Alle haben gedacht, da will uns doch jetzt jemand hier hinters Licht führen, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Aber man hat dann schnell entdeckt, oha, das ist ja genau die Signatur, wie wir sie im Prinzip erwartet haben, für das vorher schon mal durchgerechnete Beispiel und glücklicherweise schon zehn Jahre vorher mathematisch weitgehend bestätigte Modell. Aha, zwei schwarze Löcher. Und könnten das gewesen sein, wenn man jetzt sich die Frequenz anschaut und dann entsprechende Massewerte einsetzt, merkt man aha, passt auch. Und mit dem Amplitudenverlauf kann man dann auch noch, oder mit der Amplitudenstärke, kann man auch noch sagen, okay, das war jetzt 1,3 Milliarden Kilometer entfernt. Und man hatte so ein reines Signal.
Lichtjahre in diesem Fall.
Entschuldigung, natürlich. 1,3 Milliarden Lichtjahre entfernt. Und das wurde ja von zwei, also es gibt ja nicht nur einen Detektor, sondern es gibt ja zwei.
Der eine steht oben, also steht im Nordwesten der USA, im Bundesstaat Washington. Das ist, der Ort heißt Hanford, das ist ein altes Militärgelände. Riesengroß und in einer Ecke steht der Detektor in der Wüste rum. Und der andere ist in Louisiana bei Baton Rouge, also relativ dicht an der Golfküste. Mitten im Sumpf sozusagen. Und da steht der andere Detektor und man braucht zwei Detektoren. Also zum einen, wenn man nur einen Detektor hätte, würde einem niemand eine Detektion glauben. Da kann man sich den Mundfusselig reden. Die Leute werden sagen, ja, ja, komm. Da ist irgendwo ein Baum umgefallen oder das Tumbleweed übers Rohr gefegt oder was auch immer. Wenn man zwei Detektoren hat, bei denen dann der Zeitabstand stimmt, weil die Gravitationswelle sich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit ausbreitet, trifft es den einen meist eher als den anderen. Und die Signalform hängt natürlich auch ein bisschen ganz entscheidend davon ab, wie die Detektoren orientiert sind. Und die sind weit genug auseinander. Die sind also nicht an einer Ebene, sondern schon ein bisschen gekippt, weil die halt, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Kilometer es sind, aber ein paar tausend Kilometer auseinander sind. Und sie sind auch so designt, dass die Orientierung anders ist. Also der eine Detektor, wenn man von oben drauf guckt, bildet ein L und der andere ein Spiegelverkehrtes L. Damit weiß man, das Signal muss eine gewisse, die relativen Signale müssen eine gewisse Form haben. Und das passt heiser auch alles. Wir haben in der Kollaboration gibt es noch einen dritten Detektor in Italien, in der Nähe von Pisa. Die sind Advanced LIGO, hat ja gerade seinen Upgrade-Zyklus hinter sich und hat jetzt eben diese Empfindlichkeit. Dieser italienisch-französische Detektor steckt noch im Upgrade. Das heißt, da wird noch kräftig dran geschraubt. Und die Hoffnung ist, dass der im nächsten offiziellen Signs-Run, in der nächsten offiziellen Beobachtungskampagne, die im Sommer starten wird, dann auch mit dabei ist. Dann hat man drei Detektoren. Eine Sache, die aus diesem Event relativ schlecht herausgekommen ist, das war auch fast nicht anders zu erwarten, ist die Frage, wo im Universum, also die eine Sache ist die Entfernung, aber die andere ist, wo am Himmel eigentlich. In dem Factsheet, das die verbreitet haben, da steht so ein interessanter Satz vermutlich auf der Südalpkugel. Wenn man die Winkelauflösung, die wir da haben, wenn man das mit Astronomen bespricht, die schauen dann meist etwas mitleidig, weil die sind doch ganz andere Positionsauflösungen gewohnt. Aber das ist halt so, das Signal hat halt relativ kurz gedauert. Die Detektionen sind mehr oder weniger gleichmäßig über den Himmel empfindlich. Die werden auch von der Erde nicht abgeschattet, das ist vollkommen egal, ob da die Erde dazwischen ist oder nicht. Und die Auflösung, also die Frage ist, wo kommt es eigentlich her? Kann man zum einen dadurch machen, dass man, wenn man ein langes Signal hat, dann hat man natürlich die Erdrotation und der Weg der Erde um die Sonne, die dann je nachdem, wo die Quelle ist, zu den richtigen Zeiten die entsprechende Dopplerverschiebung des Signals machen. Oder man nimmt einfach mehr Detektoren und macht dann die ganz klassische Triangulation, so ein ganz kleines bisschen wie der Baumarkt Laserpointer. Wenn man sagt, das Signal kommt jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt hier an und 42 Millisekunden später hier und 23 Millisekunden später dort, dann kann das nur noch von der Stelle kommen dort oben. Aber das wird natürlich mit drei Detektoren besser als mit zwei. Also im Prinzip kann man mit zwei Detektoren schon nur eine Linie um Himmel bestimmen. Mit drei Detektoren wird es besser.
Der Virgo hätte im Prinzip laufen können, aber läuft gerade nicht.
Ob das geplant war, also in der Community werden solche Upgrades schon ein wenig synchronisiert. Also es gibt diese berühmte Supernova 1987A, die ja sozusagen einstens Jahrhundertereignisse war, weil sie halt extrem hell ist und relativ dicht bei. Und zu diesem Zeitpunkt waren durch einen unglücklichen Umstand sämtliche damals vorhandenen diese Aluminiumzylinderdetektoren nicht in Betrieb. Und das hätte durchaus sein können, wenn davon welchen Betrieb gewesen wäre, dass man das Signal, auch eine Supernova kann ein Gravitationswellensignal aussenden, einfach weil sie halt große Mengen Material wegsprengt und dann fällt es wieder zusammen. Da wird also viel beschleunigt. Die Signalform ist auch nicht ganz einfach auszurechnen, aber das hätte schon sein können, dass man was sieht. Aber wenn natürlich alle Detektoren abgeschaltet sind, sieht man nichts. Und die Gemeinschaft versucht schon, sich ein bisschen zu synchronisieren und zu sagen, dass nicht alle zur gleichen Zeit ausgeschaltet sind. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie die Planungen des Virgo-Detektors aussehen, aber soweit ich weiß, war es schon so geplant, dass die an der ersten Beobachtungskampagne nicht mit teilnehmen, weil sie noch im Upgrade-Cyclus sind. Und so ist das dann halt nicht.
Also man hätte im Prinzip schon Dritten haben können, hatte man bloß gerade nicht?
Hätte man können, wenn man anders geplant hätte vielleicht. Aber das weiß man ja nicht genau. Wer weiß, was dazwischen gekommen wäre.
Aber diese ganze Messmethodik, die wird sozusagen jetzt ausgebaut. Es kommt noch ein weiteres System in Japan noch mit dazu.
In Japan ist im Bau der sogenannte Kagera-Detektor. Meine japanischen Kollegen werden nicht begeistert sein, wenn ich jetzt sage, ich weiß nicht genau, was die Armlänge ist, aber ich glaube, es sind auch 4 Kilometer. Das Besondere an Kagera gegenüber den Detektoren, die wir jetzt haben, ist erstens, dass er unter der Erde ist. Er ist an einem Bergwerk, in einem alten Bergwerk, wo die japanische Forschungsgemeinschaft relativ viele Experimente unterbringt. Und das schafft schon mal eine gewisse Menge des Umgebungsrauschens, hält einen das schon mal vom Leib. Und der entscheidende Schritt ist aber, dass die Spiegel tiefgekühlt werden. Eine der Rauschquellen, die die Empfindlichkeit beschränkt, ist ganz einfach das, was wir das thermische Rauschen nennen, das ist die Braunschirrbewegung in den Spiegeln. Der Spiegel hat eine ähnliche Temperatur und bewegt sich deswegen.
Also der Spiegel ist ja erforderlich, weil man ja den Laser, den Arm herunterschickt, da kommt er wieder zurück und dann geht er glaube ich nochmal hin und wieder zurück. Also er durchläuft drei Spiegel.
Es sind eine Handvoll mehr als nur drei. Aber es sind sehr viele Spiegel und das entscheidende Punkt ist halt, man möchte zwischen zwei Punkten messen. Und aus rein praktischen Gründen möchte man den Laserstrahl auch mal wieder zurück haben. Das heißt, an irgendeiner Stelle muss man ein Spiegel stehen, damit man den wieder empfängt. Wenn dieser Spiegel wackelt, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, dann kann der natürlich den Empfang der Gravitationswelle stören. Im schlimmsten Fall könnte der gerade so wackeln, dass er aussieht wie eine Gravitationswelle. Aber im Allgemeinen wackelt er halt und macht nur so viel Lärm, in Anführungsstrichen, dass man die Gravitationswelle nicht mehr sehen würde. Und da gibt es ganz ausgefeilte Techniken, das Schütteln des Spiegels durch Untergrundbewegung und sowas zu verringern. Aber eine zentrale Rauschquelle ist halt, dass der Spiegel eine endliche Temperatur hat. Der ist typischerweise auf Zimmertemperatur. Da weiß man, Temperatur ist sowas wie die Bewegung der Teilchen in so einem Spiegel. Das ist ja genau das, was man verhindern möchte. Das heißt, da bewegt sich was, der schwingt auch so ein bisschen auf seiner Resonanzfrequenz. Und das sieht man auch alles ganz hervorragend im Detektor. Und wenn man das verringern möchte, bleibt einem eigentlich nur die Möglichkeit zur Zeit, die Temperatur des Spiegels zu verringern. Und wenn wir mal sagen, Zimmertemperatur ist die Größenordnung 300 Kelvin. Wenn man da auf 30 Kelvin, also die Temperatur um Faktor 10 runterbringt, und 30 Kelvin ist ungefähr die 10-fache Temperatur von flüssigem Helium, das heißt, man muss sich richtig Mühe geben, die Spiegel kalt zu machen. Das heißt, das ist eine typische Sache, die macht man nicht erstens mal so eben, und zweitens schon gar nicht im Detektor, der nicht dafür ausgelegt ist. Das heißt, das plant man besser von Anfang an, dass man die ganzen Kühlschränke sozusagen damit unterbringen kann und die Temperatur oder die Wärme aus dem Spiegel rausbekommt, sodass der schön kalt wird, und dann gehört auch ganz viel Technologie dazu. Nicht jedes Material wird besser, wenn man es kalt macht, manches wird auch schlechter. Und diese Tieftemperatur-Idee, das ist etwas, was die Community auch schon seit langer Zeit hat, aber wobei immer gesagt wird, das ist aber richtig schwierig und vor allem richtig teuer. Und die Japaner haben sich halt beschlossen, es hat keinen Sinn, jetzt noch mal das Gleiche zu bauen, sondern wenn, dann muss man noch mal versuchen, ein Stück besser zu werden, um vielleicht noch mehr oder noch andere Ereignisse zu sehen. Und ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wann die Inbetriebnahme von Karka geplant ist, aber das ist auch in der nahen Zukunft.
2017, das sind nur drei Kilometer.
Das sind drei Kilometer, danke schön, 2017. Ich hätte jetzt 18 geraten, also ich bin offensichtlich komplett ein Jahr weg, aber das ist in der mittleren Zukunft. Das ist nicht mehr 20 Jahre weg.
Dann hätten wir sozusagen im Prinzip vier vergleichbare Detektoren, die also zumindest einen Mindeststandard erfüllen, um zumindest mal zwei sich vereinigende schwarze Löcher locker mitzukommen.
Auf jeden Fall. Also die Schätzung der LIGO-Community jetzt aufgrund dieses Events ist vielleicht ein bisschen optimistisch, das weiß man vorher nicht, aber die Idee ist wohl, dass wir in der vollen Ausbaustufe, also im nächsten Sommer, also diesen Sommer, wenn sie dann wieder anfangen zu messen, sie möglicherweise eins pro Woche bekommen von diesen Events. Also dann, gut, das wird nicht jedes Mal...
Dann wissen wir aber doch schon mehr, oder? Das andere war jetzt am 14. September, jetzt sind fünf Monate vergangen.
Ich denke, man kann davon aus... Ja, aber die Messung, am 14. Januar haben sie den Detektor abgeschaltet, um die Rauschquellen, die man auch während dieses Betriebs gefunden hat und identifiziert hat, dann mit Hammer und Meißel zu Werke zu gehen, also den Detektor an der Stelle zu optimieren, dass die Rauschquellen weggehen. Und die sind mit dem ersten Lauf noch nicht an der Designempfindlichkeit gewesen. Also das wird schon noch ein oder zwei Iterationen brauchen, wo man noch mal ein bisschen schraubt und noch mal ein bisschen nachfeilt, um sozusagen an der Empfindlichkeit, um das dann wirklich auf die optimale Empfindlichkeit zu bekommen. Und ja, ich denke mal, wir haben jetzt ein Ereignis publiziert in dem Paper. Da steht ja auch drin, dass sie noch ein weiteres Ereignis, das sie nun nicht als Gravitationswelle bezeichnen, sondern relativ bescheiden als einen sogar transienten Event, also etwas, was sozusagen kurzfristig, ein kurzfristiges Signal im Detektor, was aber nicht eindeutig genug identifiziert werden kann, um zu sagen, das ist auch eine Welle. Da ist sicherlich auch viel Vorsicht. Also die Community dadurch, dass der Joe Weber in den 60er Jahren gesagt hat, ich hab ja was gemessen und das hat sich herausgestellt, mit dem Detektor nie im Leben. Und dann jetzt kürzlich das BICEP2-Ergebnis, wo die Leute gesagt haben, wir haben Gravitationswellen vom Urknall gesehen und die Kosmologie-Leute, also die Leute von der Plank-Community, also von unseren Plank-Satelliten haben gesagt, das ist ziemlich sicher Staub, was ihr da seht. Und was sich dann herausgestellt hat, das war Staub. Man kann sich als Community auch nicht allzu viele Male erlauben, da Feuer, Feuer zu schreien und das brennt nicht. Also man muss da schon eine gewisse Vorsicht walten lassen. Und ich denke mal, da sind sicherlich noch ein oder zwei Signale mehr, die man, wenn das jetzt alles, sagen wir mal, wenn das jetzt die Events 100 und 102 gewesen wären, dann wären die vielleicht veröffentlicht worden, aber nicht als Nummer 1 und Nummer 2.
Aber es ist jetzt auch keine Eile geboten? Die laufen uns nicht weg. Und GW, wie war die Nummer? GW 14?
15, ja, die 150914, also das ist tatsächlich das Datum.
Okay, das Datum, GW 1509, 1514, ne, 0914, weil Jahr, Monat, Tag, genau. Das habe ich es auch. 0914, da bestehen keine Zweifel.
Na, keine sinnvollen. Also, Wissenschaft lebt von Zweifeln. Also das ist schon so. Und es ist auch so, dass ein gewisser Ikonoklasmus uns allen inne wohnt. Also man macht sich natürlich einen größeren Namen, wenn man ein sensationales Resultat vom Sockel stößt. Aber nee, da gibt es keine sinnvollen Zweifel.
Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wie geht es weiter? Und zwar einerseits natürlich stellt sich erstmal die Frage, jetzt wo wir keine Supernovae gesehen haben, gibt es überhaupt eine gute Bezeichnung für die Vereinigung von zwei schwarzen Löchern? Hat es da jetzt einen schönen Namen, wo man weiß, dass es das gibt?
Also wir reden tatsächlich von der Verschmelzung zweier schwarzen Löcher. Im Englischen heißt es Merger. Im Deutschen ist der Begriff vielleicht noch etwas sperriger, aber wir haben da noch keinen öffentlichkeitskompatiblen Namen gefunden. Ja, vielleicht könnten wir vielleicht mal mit Heinz oder Paul oder sowas anfangen. Aber nein, auch doppelsterrensystem ist ja schon ein, oder doppelschwarzes Lochsystem ist ja schon ein gewisser sperriger Begriff. Also da wird sich sicherlich schon noch was einbürgern. Die Leute irgendwann keine Lust mehr haben, sich jedes Mal bei dem Wort im Vortrag zu verhaspeln und sich da ein kürzeres einbürgern.
Auf jeden Fall irgendwas, was mir fetzt. Aber man weiß jetzt irgendwie, gibt's, hat man gesehen. Man kann jetzt glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, auch sagen, hätte diese Supernova, vor wieviel Jahren war das?
Da, 1907,8, das sind jetzt 30 Jahre, fast 29 Jahre.
Also würde die jetzt heute stattfinden und die Ligos wären in Betrieb?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Weiß ich nicht. Bei Supernova ist immer ein gewisser Risikofaktor dabei. Das Signal, wie stark das Signal ist, hängt ganz stark davon ab, wie asymmetrisch das Ding explodiert. Also wenn das perfekt kugelsymmetrisch ist, sendet das gar kein Signal aus. Und wenn das so in zwei Teilen auseinanderfliegt, dann sendet das mehr Signal aus. Was da typischerweise dabei rauskommt, das ist extrem, extrem kompliziert zu berechnen. Das machen auch sehr wenige Leute. Und die, die das machen, dürfen nicht drüber reden, weil das typischerweise die gleichen Computerprogramme ist, mit denen Kernwaffenexplosionen simuliert werden. Aber das kann sein, dass wenn wir noch mal so eine sehen, dass Lago die sieht. Das hängt wie gesagt davon ab, wie genau das abläuft. Wird man dann sehen, tatsächlich ist es ja so, dass eine Supernova in unserer Milchstraße überfällig ist. Und zwar schon seit geraumer Zeit. Also die letzte Beobachtete war glaube ich 1517 gewesen. Und die Rate ist so einmal alle 200 Jahre oder sowas. Also es wird mal wieder Zeit, dass was passiert. Die würde man auf jeden Fall sehen, das ist dicht genug dran. Ob man die in der Nachbargalaxie sehen würde, hängt dann davon ab. Supernovae sind immer etwas unangenehme Quellen, weil man da immer dazu sagen muss, ja, wenn es dann die richtige Supernova ist, dann sieht man sie. Das Problem hat man bei den sehr sauberen Signalen, die von schwarzen Löchern kommen, nicht mehr. Da ist ja auch keine Materie mehr als solches beteiligt. Das sind einfach schwarze Löcher. Das macht das Signal so schön, so sauber. Weil man muss sich nicht mehr damit rumärgern, ob da Staub dazwischen war, die was absorbiert hat. Man muss sich nicht damit rumärgern, ob da vielleicht noch irgendwo Massen irgendwelche Trümmer links und rechts drum rumhängen, die noch was reflektieren. Das passiert einfach nicht. Das kommt nur von den schwarzen Löchern. Und es ist trotzdem die Numerik relativ aufwendig. Das wird man nicht auf dem iPhone rechnen können. Jedenfalls nicht auf dem iPhone 6. Vielleicht auf dem iPhone 12 mal oder so. Aber im Moment braucht es dafür halt schon noch richtige Computer. Du hast den, was relativ aufwendig ist zu rechnen, ist die physikalische Interpretation relativ einfach. Einfach, weil es nur von ganz wenigen Parametern abhängt und nicht von irgendwas, was man nicht so genau im Griff hat.
Was denkt man denn, was man vielleicht noch messen kann, außer schwarzen Löchern, die sich vereinigen? Supernovae, die asymmetrisch explodieren und Neutronensterne, die zusammenfallen?
Das hängt so ein bisschen davon ab, in welchem Frequenzbereich wir schauen könnten. Jetzt mit den bodengebundenen Detektoren sind wir ja mit den Frequenzen sozusagen auf den, sagen wir mal, akustischen Bereich beschränkt. Also die können bis Frequenzen vielleicht für 10 Hertz, 15 Hertz so an der unteren Grenze bis vielleicht ein Kilo Hertz an der oberen Grenze. Also so ein bisschen tiefer als das, was wir hören können, aber so im Prinzip schon akustisch. Und das liegt einfach daran, dass die Erde stört. Also es wackelt hier so viel, dass man bei niedrigen Frequenzen einfach nichts messen kann.
Es rumpelt einfach.
Es rumpelt, Tiefdrucksysteme, Magma-Ströme. Bei niedrigen Frequenzen ist die Erde kein angenehmer Platz. Wenn man zu niedrigen Frequenzen gucken könnten, dann ist man sich eigentlich ziemlich sicher, dass man auch sehr spektakuläre Sachen sehen würde, so wie jetzt diese beiden schwarzen Löcher, die also so ungefähr 30 Sonnenmassen hatten.
Mit wieviel Herz wurden die denn eingefallen? Das war ja so im hörbaren Bereich.
War im hörbaren Bereich.
Das war unverfälscht sozusagen diese Frequenz?
Ja, das was dann auf der Pressekonferenz hörbar gemacht worden ist, ist glaube ich ein Faktor 10 hoch transponiert worden, weil sonst tatsächlich nur brummt. Es ist so bei 20 Herz oder sowas. Genau weiß ich die Frequenz gerade nicht, aber ist relativ niederfrequent gewesen. Was eigentlich auch von der Geschichte her logisch ist, denn das ist dort, wo die Ausbaustufe, die wir jetzt haben mit LIGO, den meisten Fortschritt gebracht hat gegenüber vorherigen Detektoren. Also in dem Bereich ist die Empfindlichkeit am stärksten gewachsen.
Soll ich mal kurz einspielen?
Der Chirp, ja. Ja, sehr schön. Ja, ich denke mal so 20 Hertz oder sowas. Ich hab was von 25 Millisekunden in Erinnerung. Das sind dann 50 Hertz. Ein bisschen niedriger wird's gewesen sein. Also wenn wir jetzt noch zu noch niedrigeren Frequenzen gehen, also sagen wir mal so Millihertz, also Zeitskalen von 1000 Sekunden. Das ist vielleicht einfacher zu visualisieren als ausgerechnet ein Millihertz. Oder Zeitskalen von Stunden oder sogar viele Stunden. Da haben wir dann Objekte, das sind keine 30 Sonnenmassen mehr, das sind dann 100.000 Sonnenmassen. Oder eine Million Sonnenmassen. Und solche Sachen, solche Schwarzen Löcher, die so schwer sind, da wissen wir, in unserer Milchstraße ist im Zentrum eins davon. Das hat ungefähr vier Millionen Sonnenmassen. Wir gehen davon aus, dass, wir haben auch noch in anderen Galaxien auch detektiert, aber wir gehen eigentlich davon aus, dass die meisten Galaxien ein schwarzes Loch im Zentrum haben. Und wenn du dir jetzt vorstellst, dass sich so zwei Galaxien treffen, und das passiert dann schon mal gelegentlich in den letzten 13 Milliarden Jahren, dann irgendwann treffen sich auch mal die Schwarzen Löcher. Und genauso wie diese beiden, die 30 Sonnenmassen verschmelzen, verschmelzen dann halt auch zwei Schwarze Löcher, die eine Million Sonnenmassen haben.
Also die beiden, die wir jetzt beobachtet haben, waren wahrscheinlich nicht Zentren von einer Galaxie?
Ganz sicher sogar nicht, nein. Das sind eher solche Sachen.
So lokale Phänomene.
Man weiß nicht so richtig klar, ist das nicht, wo die herkommen. Das ist sicherlich, da sind vermutlich auch schon wieder Dutzende von Papern unterwegs, die sich überlegen, wie man denn 30 sonnenmassenschwere Schwarze Löcher tatsächlich herstellen kann. Und da gibt es sicherlich genügend Ideen. Aber so in den Zentren von Galaxien, da sammelt sich das dann sozusagen, die Masse.
Da ist schwer was los.
Ja, da ist schwer was los, in der Tat. Und wenn zwei solche aufeinander stoßen, das ist natürlich auch ein enormes Signal. Dieses Ereignis, was jetzt detektiert wurde, das hat innerhalb von relativ kurzer Zeit die Masse von drei Sonnen in Gravitationswellen umgesetzt.
Ich hab gehört, das sei dann 50 Mal mehr Energieausstoß gewesen als alle Sterne des Universums.
Ja, das ist das mit großem Abstand das hältste Objekt im Universum. Der Vergleich funktioniert nur dann, wenn man sagt, ich sammle mal alles Licht aller Sterne ein im Universum und vergleiche das mit der Energie der Gravitationswelle, die da rausgekommen ist. Es gibt vermutlich noch andere Gravitationswellen, also dann passt der Vergleich nicht mehr so richtig. Aber drei Sonnenmassen in, sagen wir mal, 10 Millisekunden oder so ist viel. Es ist wirklich viel. Und wenn du dir überlegst, so Gamma-Ray-Bursts, das waren immer so die hellsten und energiereichsten Objekte im Universum, da sind wir ungefähr bei Faktor 10 drüber. Und nur man sieht halt nichts. Und solche großen Systeme, die strahlen im Übrigen genau die gleiche Leistung ab, aber mehr Energie, das heißt, es wird nicht heller, es dauert nur länger. Das heißt, nicht im Bruchteil einer Sekunde, sondern vielleicht auf Zeitskalen von 100 Sekunden oder so was. Solche Objekte sieht man aus der Frühzeit des Universums. Wenn da zwei schwarze Löcher im Bereich von einer Million Sonnenmassen kollidieren, dann sieht man das im Wesentlichen bis zu der Zeit zurück, wo sich die ersten Galaxien gebildet haben. Da sieht man jedes einzelne Ereignis im Universum mit einem Detektor, der in dem Frequenzbereich empfindlich ist. Und wenn man sagt, was sehen wir denn sonst noch? Wenn man ehrlich ist, das wissen wir nicht. Wir haben eine Handvoll von Quellen, von denen wir stark vermuten, dass wir sie sehen werden, z.B. die Neutronensterne oder mit einem Weltraum gestützten Detektor auch Signale von Doppelsternsystemen unserer Galaxie, die also noch lange nicht verschmelzen, sondern noch so eine Million Jahre vor sich haben, bevor sie dann endgültig ineinander stürzen. Man würde mit ganz viel Glück und wenn die passenden Theorien dann auch stimmen, vielleicht sogar Sachen sehen, die kurz nach dem Urknall entstanden sind Gravitationswellen, aber das ist, sagen wir mal, vorsichtig mit hoch spekulativ. Aber ich denke mal, ein großer Teil der Entdeckungen werden Dinge ausmachen, von denen wir jetzt noch nicht wissen, dass sie da sind. Einfach weil wir sie elektromagnetisch nicht sehen, gar nicht. Nicht mal als, bei Gamma-Ray-Bursts sagen die Leute ja auch, na das sind ja vielleicht zwei Zusammenstoßen Neutronensterne. Aber ja, vielleicht auch nicht. Also das weiß eigentlich auch keiner.
Jetzt ist ja unser Universum, wie wir seit einiger Zeit wissen, voll mit Zeug, was man nicht sieht. Die dunkle Materie, man weiß nur, irgendwas ist da, weil ansonsten würde es mit der Gravitation nicht hinhauen mit der sichtbaren Materie. Das heißt, jetzt haben wir hier etwas, was man nicht sieht, was aber definitiv enorme Gravitationsauswirkungen hat. Kann es sein, dass jetzt hier sozusagen auf sich irgendwas geobachtet ist auf einmal?
Kann sein. Da würde ich aber erstmal noch mal den Ball ein bisschen flach halten, denn es liegt natürlich nahe zu sagen, jetzt haben wir jetzt was entdeckt und davon muss es ganz, ganz viele geben, sonst hätten wir das nicht so früh entdeckt. Ist das nicht vielleicht dunkle Materie? Naja, ich glaube, die Idee, dass schwarze Löcher einen großen Anteil der dunklen Materie machen, der ist nicht besonders neu, die Idee.
Aber das könnte so ja sein.
Das haben die Leute sich alles schon mal angeguckt. Und dann kann man sich fragen, was passiert denn, wenn hier unsere Milchstraße, bei der wir ja auch schon sehen, dass die Rotationskurven, also dass die Materie in den äußeren Bezirken der Milchstraße sich eigentlich viel zu schnell bewegt, wenn nur die Sterne in der Milchstraße wären, dann würden die sich bei der Rotationsgeschwindigkeit wegfliegen. Das heißt, man weiß, es muss irgendwas sein in der Milchstraße und in vielen anderen Galaxien auch, was schwer ist, was Masse hat, sodass die äußeren Sterne stark genug angezogen werden, damit die sich mit der Geschwindigkeit bewegen können. Und es ist vermutlich irgendwas, was nicht leuchtet und auch irgendwas, was nicht absorbiert. Weil sonst würden wir ja dunkle Flecken sehen oder helle Flecken. Die würden wir halt nicht sehen. Und da kann man sich natürlich überlegen, Mensch, vielleicht sind das schwarze Löcher, aber das haben sich die Leute natürlich alle schonmal angeguckt. Die Idee ist ja naheliegend. Und da kann man sich dann fragen, wenn da so viel von den schwarzen Löchern da rumeiern, müssten die nicht gelegentlich mal dadurch sichtbar werden, dass die auf Sterne treffen? Und soweit ich weiß, ist das zwar eine hübsche Idee, aber das erklärt es nicht so hundertprozentig. Aber man kann das nicht ausschließen. Ich meine, das ist das Schöne daran. Wir sehen jetzt Dinge, die wir vorher nicht gesehen haben. Wer weiß das schon, was dabei noch rüberkommt.
Jetzt haben wir ja viel um Heißenbrei herum geredet, weil letztlich sitzen wir ja hier auch bei der ESA. Und bisher hat all das, was wir gesprochen haben, eigentlich mit Raumfahrt und auch mit der ESA herzlich wenig zu tun. Aber es gibt natürlich einen Bezug. Und zwar eine Mission, oder sagen wir mal ein riesiges Experiment, was vorbereitet wird unter dem Namen LISA. Was es irgendwann mal geben soll, was aber jetzt noch nicht gebaut ist und auch noch gar nicht irgendwo hin unterwegs ist. Aber auch hier geht es um die Messung von Gravitationswellen. Und wenn ich das jetzt auch schon mal so richtig rausgehört habe, vor allem die Messung von Gravitationswellen, eben an einem Ort, wo man eben diese blubbernde Erde nicht die ganze Zeit noch im Weg hat, so wie man die Teleskope ins All verlagert hat, einfach die filternde und rauschende und störende Funktion der Erdatmosphäre loszuwerden, möchte man jetzt auch im Weltall Gravitationswellen messen, damit man eben dieses Rauschen los ist?
Genau, das ist also genau die richtige Analogie. Man möchte das Rauschen der Erde loswerden, man möchte in einem Frequenzbereich schauen, der von der Erde aus nicht zugänglich ist. Und wenn man das unter dem Stichwort Gravitationswellenastronomie versteht, dann ist das ungefähr so, dass man sagt, auf der Erde kann man keine Röntgenstrahlen beobachten, weil dann bauen wir halt unsere Satelliten, schicken die in Orbit und lassen von dort die Röntgenstrahlenquellen beobachten. Oder auf der Erde macht die Atmosphäre zu viel Störung, dann bauen wir halt einen Hubble oder einen JWST und setzen das in Orbit und empfangen dort mehr oder bessere Bilder. So ein bisschen in die Richtung geht das auch. Ich sag, wir sind ungefähr ein Faktor 1000 oder so unter der Frequenz der bodengestützten Detektoren, so über den Daumen. Und vielleicht sogar ein Faktor 10.000, aber im Wesentlichen ist dann das sozusagen, was sind die Objekte, die man sich dann anschauen kann. Und das ist dann bei gravitationsgebundenen Systemen auch immer ganz einfach, die sind dann halt gleich auch ein Faktor 10.000 oder so schwerer und größer und erzählen uns andere Geschichten. Also da wird es dann weniger um zum Beispiel, wie kriege ich eigentlich 30 sonnenmassenschwere schwarze Löcher überhaupt gebaut mit Sternen, sondern da geht es mehr darum, wie kriege ich eigentlich Galaxien zusammengebaut. Warum haben wir Galaxien in unserem Universum? Wie haben die sich entwickelt? Haben die sich um die schwarzen Löcher gescharrt? Oder sind die schwarzen Löcher aus den Galaxien entstanden? Wie hängt das eigentlich alles zusammen? Zum Beispiel auch, wie hängt das mit diesem berühmten Cosmic Wrap zusammen? Also diese Simulationen, die sagen, dass sich irgendwann die Materie angefangen hat zusammenzuklumpen und da sind dann die Galaxien drum herum entstanden. Und man sieht ja auch im Universum relativ großskalige Strukturen. Und es kann auch um solche ganz einfachen Fragen gehen, dann schon wieder in unserer Galaxie allerdings. Wie viele Sterne, wie viele Doppelsternsysteme sehen wir eigentlich in unserer Galaxie? Optisch wissen wir, sind eine ganze Menge da, aber da kommt man halt nur eine gewisse Strecke weit, weil überall Staub und sowas dazwischen ist. Da ist man dann mit Gravitationswellen unabhängig. Man öffnet sozusagen ein anderes Fenster in dieses Gravitationswellenuniversum. Insofern ist natürlich diese Entdeckung, die wir jetzt hatten, mit den bodengestützten Detektoren fast das Beste, was einem passieren kann. Wenn das jetzt ein strecklich langweiliges Objekt gewesen wäre, wo man gesagt hätte, klar, das kennen wir doch schon. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, dass ihr das jetzt endlich auch in Gravitationswellen seht. Aber dadurch, dass man da jetzt was hat, was man optisch nicht sieht, ist das natürlich sozusagen ein riesiges Geschenk, weil man jetzt natürlich klar vor Augen hat, dass in dem Moment, wo man irgendwo hinguckt, wo man vorher nicht hingucken konnte, ziemlich sicher was findet, was man vorher nicht wusste, dass es gibt.
Ist man sich denn total sicher, dass so zwei Schwarze Löcher, die sich vereinigen, dass das kein sichtbares Licht abgehen würde?
Das ist man sich nicht sicher. Da gibt es also Schwarze Löcher, haben ja typischerweise sogenannte Aggressionsscheiben um sich herum. Also die sammeln dann halt irgendwelche Trümmer, die noch da sind, ein und die fallen dann relativ in irgendwelchen kurzen Zeitskalen auf das Schwarze Loch runter. Und da gibt es dann auch immer, wenn da Gas angesaugt wird, dann können die in Röntgenstrahlenbereich leuchten und so was. Es ist überhaupt gar nicht sicher, dass man da kein optisches...
Und die krümmen ja auch ganz ordentlich den Raum. Also man hat ja auf jeden Fall diesen Linseneffekt um so Schwarze Löcher herum.
Den hat man aber bei 30 Sonnenmassen ist der nach so groß noch nicht. Ich meine, der krümmt den Raum genauso wie 30 Sonnenmassen. Kein bisschen mehr und kein bisschen weniger. Da braucht man dann richtig große Systeme, um solche damit wirklich große, also wahrnehmbare Gravitationslinsen zu haben. Das Objekt, das wir jetzt haben, das ist Giga-Lichtjahre weg. Ja, oder sowas in dem Bereich.
Da könnte ja sein, dass auch so zwei kleine Schwarze Löcher in unserer Galaxis zusammenklatschen.
Und dann sieht man ja eine Änderung vielleicht. Ja, in der Tat, das wäre dann noch spektakulärer im Signal.
Diese Idee jetzt ins Weltall zu gehen mit Lisa. Das heißt ja, dass man im Prinzip dieselbe Messtechnik, also diese Interferometrie mit Lasern, auch dort zum Einsatz bringen will. Oder kommt dann eine komplett andere Reflektur der Frage?
Da nehmen wir genau das Gleiche. Einfach auch schon aus rein praktischen Gründen, niedrige Frequenzen heißen dann auch, da können wir uns dann auch längere Arme im Interferometer erlauben. Also, LIGO hat vier Kilometer. Wir zielen da so auf mehrere Millionen Kilometer. Das kann man eigentlich nur mit nicht-materiellen Dingen machen, also mit Licht. Niemand käme auf die wahnwitzige Idee, eine vier Millionen Kilometer lange Struktur irgendwo zu bauen. Das geht nicht. Also, das ist vollkommen impraktikabel, selbst wenn man das unbedingt wollte. Das ist schlicht nicht zu leisten. Aber mit Licht auf dem Boden haben wir halt das Problem, dass wir große Vakumsysteme haben, mit Röhren, die wir leer pumpen müssen. Das gibt es da oben umsonst. Das müssen wir nicht extra bezahlen. Dafür hat man halt das Problem, dass man den anderen Satelliten in ein paar Millionen Kilometer Entfernung treffen muss.
Wir müssen kurz mal erklären, was ist sozusagen die Idee von LISA? Wofür steht das und was soll es sein?
Also, LISA ist wie viele Dinge in der Astronomie ein etwas holpriges Akronym für Laser Interferometer Space Antenne. Außerdem klingt es hübsch. Aber es geht also tatsächlich darum, im Wesentlichen einen solchen Detektor wie LIGO ins Weltall zu bringen. So ein Interferometer besteht aus vielen Spiegeln, wie wir vorhin schon gesagt haben. Aber der Kern der Sache ist, man hat zwei Arme. Bei LIGO sind die 90 Grad zueinander. Und man schickt das Licht den einen Arm entlang und bekommt es zurück. Und man schickt das Licht den anderen Arm entlang und bekommt es zurück. Und dann vereinigt man das Licht auf dem Beam, auf dem Strahlteiler. Und dann schickt man es auf eine Fotodiode. Und so ähnlich würden wir das bei Lisa auch machen. Nur, dass wir aus rein praktischen Gründen da nicht überall Spiegel hinstellen können, weil dann kommt kein Licht mehr zurück, weil sich der Strahl zu weit ausdehnt. Da kommen ein paar technische Tricks zustande. Aber im Wesentlichen schicken wir auch Licht entlang des einen Arms und bekommen Licht zurück und messen dessen Phase. Und machen das auf dem anderen Arm auch. Und messen die Phase. Und vergleichen dann die beiden Phasen miteinander. Und wenn eine Gravitationswelle durchkommt, dann wird der eine Arm wie bei LIGO auch ein Stückchen kürzer, der andere ein bisschen länger. Und dann wieder andersrum. Und so was, das würden wir dann in der Messung sehen. Bei Lisa kommt er noch hinzu, weil man sowieso drei Satelliten braucht. Nämlich einen, von dem das Licht ausgesendet wird. Und zwei am Ende jedes Arms. Da kann man dann einmal drauf gucken und feststellen, wenn ich dann noch einen dritten Arm baue, zwischen den beiden Endsatelliten, dann kann ich drei identische Satelliten nehmen. Dann sieht das nämlich an jeder Stelle gleich aus. Identische Satelliten ist immer schön, das spart Geld. Weil man nicht alles doppelt und dreifach bauen muss, aber immerhin das Gleiche dreifach bauen muss. Und dann hat man halt statt zwei Arme drei Arme und dann kann man an einigen Stellen noch einige Rauschquellen systematischer ausschließen und so was. Weil auf dem Boden haben wir zwei Detektoren. Im Weltall hatten wir dann einen, da können wir uns nicht noch einen zweiten leisten. Das heißt, da hat man dann genau das Problem, was ich am Anfang gesagt hatte, wenn du nur einen Detektor hast, dann glaubt das kein Mensch. Das heißt, da muss man sich mehr Mühe geben, den Leuten klar zu machen, dass man da nicht ein eigenartiges Rauschen gemessen hat.
Das Ziel ist, drei Satelliten zu bauen, die technisch identisch sind. Das heißt, jeder kann Laser senden und jeder kann einen empfangen.
Genau, er sendet sogar zwei Laser raus. Zum einen Satelliten und zum anderen. Jeder Ecke des Dreiecks, stell dir einfach ein gleichseitiges Dreieck vor, an jeder Ecke sitzt ein Satellit und jeder schickt sich jedem anderen. Das heißt, jeder schickt zwei und empfängt zwei. Die Daten, die Phasen der Laser, werden dann gemessen und registriert.
Und dabei hat man im Prinzip auch drei Detektoren im Weltall.
Die sind dabei leider nicht unabhängig, weil die immer einen Arm miteinander teilen. Wenn man sich das genau und lange genug überlegt, dann sind das nur zwei Detektoren und nicht drei. Aber ja, es ist mehr als ein Detektor. Das hilft so ein bisschen bei der Suche nach Rauschquellen. Das hilft auch, was im Weltall immer eine Frage ist. Man kann ja nichts reparieren. Das ist weit außerhalb des Zugriffbereichs von Astronauten. Das heißt, das Zeug muss funktionieren. Und wenn was kaputt geht, dann hat man ganz gerne sozusagen eine Ersatzlösung vor Ort. Und wenn man jetzt, sagen wir mal, drei Satelliten und sagen wir mal, einer der Laser geht kaputt, dann hat man immer noch zwei Arme, die laufen, und nur einer nicht. Und das ist dann immer noch besser, als wenn man nur zwei Arme hat und ein Laser ist kaputt, dann hat sich das erledigt mit der Mission. Und in dem Sinne, ich denke nicht, dass man drei Satelliten bauen würde, wenn man sie nicht ohnehin brauchen würde für so eine Geometrie. Ein Arm geht nicht, weil wir bis heute immer noch einen zweiten Arm brauchen, gegen den wir das vergleichen können. Weil bei den Empfindlichkeiten, die wir brauchen, haben wir keine andere Referenzmessung, die uns erlaubt, sozusagen keine andere Nullmessung. Wenn wir eine Uhr hätten, die genau genug wäre, dann könnte man vielleicht mit einem Arm auskommen, aber die Uhren, die wir ins Weltall schicken können, sind viele Größenordnungen zu schlecht. Also wir brauchen zwei Arme mindestens, und der dritte ist dann, naja, weil es geht halt, ja.
Ich habe gelesen, dass die Genauigkeit bei dem LIGO, also das, was da sozusagen an Veränderungen der Wegstrecke gemessen wird, in etwa so ein Tausendstel eines Proton-Durchmessers entspricht.
Ja, das passt ungefähr.
Das ist ja sehr klein.
Sehr wenig, ja. Wer kann sich schon vorstellen, wie groß ein Proton ist, und geschweige denn, was ein Tausendstel davon ist.
Das ist schwierig, ja.
Es ist schwierig, es ist sehr klein. Das ist halt, Gravitationswellen machen sehr kleine Effekte. Wenn die sehr viel größer wären, hätten wir sie schon früher entdeckt. Und der Trick ist halt, dass man alle anderen Sachen, die auch sozusagen so ähnlich aussehen und davor sich hinklappern in so einem Detektor, möglichst ruhig halten muss. Und den Vorteil hat man im Weltall, da laufen keine Leute rum, da gibt es kein Wetter, da gibt es keine Erde, die unter einem wackelt. Der Weltraum kann ein sehr ruhiger Ort sein, wenn man es richtig macht. Und das heißt, der Teil der Messung wird ein bisschen einfacher, weil man sich mit den Rauschquellen, jedenfalls mit diesen Rauschquellen, nicht rumärgern muss. Dafür wird natürlich der Teil, wo man sagt, wo man eben an den bodengestützten Direktoren mal eben Mitarbeiter hinschickt und sagt, klopft doch mal gegen, dass wir mal sehen können, ob das Problem von dem kommt. Oder da müssen wir mal eben den Widerstand austauschen. Das geht natürlich im Weltall nicht. Das heißt, da muss man an der Komplexität des Instruments ganz starke Abstriche machen. So etwas, wenn ich gesagt habe, wir wollen LIGO im Weltall haben, so etwas Komplexes wie LIGO, das kriegen wir nicht gebaut im Weltall. Das geht nicht. Das ist eine sehr, sehr, in der Komplexität sehr, sehr reduzierte Version. Und wir sind viele, viele, also wenn LIGO davon redet, den 1000. Durchmesser eines Protons zu messen, da sind wir weit davon entfernt. Wir sind also, ich vermute mal, eher so viele, auf dem Niveau viele hundert Protonen bei LISA. Und wir machen das einfach dadurch widerwett, dass wir nicht nur vier Kilometer haben, sondern ein paar Millionen Kilometer.
Das heißt, das ist sozusagen der angedachte Abstand, den die Satelliten untereinander haben.
Wir reden von einem gleichseitigen Dreieck, wo die Seitenlängen, sagen wir mal, so zweieinhalb Millionen Kilometer lang sind. Das kommt so genau nicht drauf an. Das können zwei oder drei sein, aber so in der Größenordnung.
Aber was bringt diese Länge, wenn man jetzt eigentlich nicht so genau detektieren kann?
Gravitationswellen, der Effekt von Gravitationswellen hängt davon ab, wie groß das Instrument ist. Wenn das ein Interferometer, wo die Arme vier Kilometer lang sind, wenn man das mit einem Interferometer vergleicht, wo die Arme, sagen wir mal, vier Millionen Kilometer lang sind, dann ist der Effekt einer Gravitationswelle in dem vier Millionen Kilometer großen Interferometer eine Million Mal größer. Das heißt, der Effekt, das Signal, was kommt, ist größer. Das heißt, ich kann es mir erlauben, entsprechend unempfindlicher zu messen.
Das ist zwar ein Nachteil, der aber wettgemacht wird, einfach durch die schiere Größe.
Genau, und der Nachteil, also das ist halt die Frage, baut man ein extrem komplexiertes Experiment in einer relativ kompakten Version im Weltall oder baut man ein relativ einfaches Instrument extrem groß? Und da der Platz im Wesentlichen umsonst ist, davon muss man nicht bezahlen, ist es sehr viel einfacher, ein einfaches Instrument einfach sehr viel größer zu machen und die Empfindlichkeit dadurch zu bekommen.
Naja, also das klingt ja jetzt total einfach. Da schickt man mal eben so drei Satelliten hoch und die sollen dann irgendwie einen Laserstrahl auf eine Million Kilometer aufeinander zeigen lassen und das so gut, dass man da kleinste Bewegungen rausmessen kann. Wie will man denn das machen?
Na wenn das so einfach wäre, das klingt natürlich immer sehr einfach, aber der Teufel liegt natürlich im Detail. Also zum einen ist das natürlich eine Frage der technologischen Machbarkeit. Können wir überhaupt Laser bauen, die stabil genug sind und lange genug funktionieren? Das war lange Zeit eine offene Frage. Ich glaube, das hat sich in der Zwischenzeit mit den Laserterminals, die die Kollegen von der Nachrichtentechnik im Orbit haben, das hat sich das mehr oder weniger erledigt. Da ist der technische Fortschritt drüber hinweg gegangen. Das wird in der Zwischenzeit einfach gesagt, ja klar, Laser können wir auf dem Satelliten bauen. Der eigentliche zentrale Punkt ist, wir müssen auch bei Lisa, was in den bodengestützten Detektoren, das hatte ich ja schon erwähnt, eine sehr ausgefeilte Technik, die dafür sorgt, dass die Spiegel nicht wackeln, wenn da Leute drum herumlaufen oder was auch immer. Gut, wir haben keine Leute im Weltall, aber was wir im Weltall haben, wir haben die Sonne. Die können wir erstens nicht abschalten, zweitens brauchen wir die auch zur Stromerzeugung. Die Sonnenstrahlung ist bei Laib nicht konstant. Die wird mal heller, mal ein bisschen dunkler. Also da ist auch ein gewisser Rauscheffekt drauf. Und um trotzdem Gravitationswellen messen zu können, benutzen wir die Satelliten dazu, um die Testmassen, sagen wir mal die Spiegel, von den Effekten des Weltausends abzuschirmen. Das heißt, jeder Satellit hat sozusagen in seinem Inneren, nennen wir sie mal Spiegel, aber in Wirklichkeit sind das so 4 cm große Metallwürfel. Zwei davon. Und der Satellit versucht jetzt, nichts anderes zu machen, als immer den Abstand zu diesen Testmassen zu halten. Die sind also frei im Inneren des Satelliten. Und wir messen also immer den Abstand zwischen Testmasse und Satellit. Und dann steuern wir die Triebwerke entsprechend, sodass wir immer um diesen Metallklotz drumrum fliegen. Sodass der Satellit sozusagen alle Störungen abbekommt. Aber wir messen zwischen Testmasse und Testmasse. Oder zwischen Spiegel und Spiegel. Und dann stört das nicht, dass der Satellit sich da drum noch bewegt. Die Testmasse wird nicht angefasst. Und das ist natürlich erstens eine Technologie, die bis vor kurzem nicht vorhanden war. Also man kann sich das zwar simulieren und ausrechnen. Und jeder sagt einem ja, das wird schon funktionieren. Aber im Weltraum ist man konservativ. Man gibt nicht ganz viel Geld aus für irgendwas, was vielleicht funktioniert. Man möchte das schon mal gemacht haben, um sicher zu sein, dass es funktioniert. Und das ist für so einen Gravitationswellendetektor im All, was wir als drag-free oder, sagen wir mal, störungsfreien Flug bezeichnen, eine extrem kritische Sache, das muss funktionieren. Und das machen wir gerade, wir haben uns hier gerade unterhalten, wir haben im Dezember eine Technologie-Demonstrator-Mission gestartet, Lisa Pathseinder, die ist im Orbit. Und die probiert im Wesentlichen genau das aus. Auch dort sind zwei Massen drin und der Abstand zwischen den beiden Massen wird auch mit einem Laser-Interferometer gemessen, das ist wie Lisa nur ein Faktor von ein paar Millionen kleiner. Und alles, was wir versuchen, ist zu messen, wie stark sich diese beiden Massen noch gegeneinander bewegen, wenn wir den Satelliten sozusagen dazu benutzen, die von allen Umwelteinflüssen abzuschirmen. Sodass wir anschließend sagen können, das ist sozusagen eine kritische Sache für einen Gravitationswellendetektor. Da haben wir jetzt einen Haken dahinter gemacht. Wir wissen genau, wie wir das bauen. Und nicht nur wissen wir genau, wie wir das bauen, wir wissen auch sehr genau, wie sich das dann im All verhält. Weil das ist eine Sache, die kann man auf dem Boden nicht testen, weil die sind im freien Fall diese Testmassen. Hier auf dem Boden kriegt man einen freien Fall vielleicht von ein paar Sekunden hin. Oder wenn man über einen Schacht geht, dann sind es vielleicht 10 Sekunden, aber viel länger auch nicht. Das heißt, wenn man wissen will, wie sich Effekte auf Zeitskalen von vielen Stunden auswirken, das wird auf der Erde nichts. Und da muss man dann also tatsächlich ins All, das haben wir jetzt gerade. Wir sind gestern und vorgestern haben wir also die letzten mechanischen Kontakte zu diesen Testmassen. Während des Startes waren die festgehalten, damit die nicht durch die Gegend rappeln. Jetzt den mechanischen Kontakte haben wir also zurückgezogen. Der Satellit hat jetzt die beiden Testmassen in seinem Inneren und kann die also nur noch durch elektromagnetische Kräfte ganz leicht steuern. Und nächste Woche scheiden wir die auch ab. Dann guckt der Satellit nur noch, wo sind die Testmassen, und sieht zu, dass er drum herum fliegt. Ja, sehr viel genauer als das. Also es ist schon erstaunlich, wenn man in so einem Kontrollraum sitzt und sich klar macht, dass wir jetzt in ungefähr anderthalb Millionen Kilometern, das ist also ungefähr auf einem Prozent zur Entfernung zur Sonne, steht der Satellit im Moment, da bleibt er auch, dass wir da Messungen durchführen können auf ein Milliardstel Meter. Und das Ziel ist dann nochmal, so in die Gegend eines Milliardstel Millimeters zu kommen. Das machen wir dann etwas später. Dazu müssen wir dann, wie gesagt, diese letzten Haltekräfte, die wir noch haben, abschalten, damit nicht das, was denn im Moment, wenn der Satellit geschüttelt wird, schütteln die Testmassen der Mitte noch ein bisschen mit, weil wir da noch die elektromagnetische Halterung haben. Wenn wir die auch abschalten, dann fliegt der frei. Und dann sehen wir nur noch das Verhalten der Testmassen oder der Spiegel. Das ist in diesem Fall das gleiche, aber wie gesagt, eine kleine Metallwürfel. Und da werden wir dann sehen, dass wir auf die angestrebte Empfindlichkeit kommen.
Also, müssen wir mal zusammenzufassen. Das Ziel ist, Laser zu bauen. Laser soll aus drei Satelliten bestehen. Die beschicken sich mit Lasern und schießen diese Laser auf diese freifliegenden Würfel, die auch noch Detektoren haben. Das werden wir vielleicht gleich nochmal erklären, wie das funktioniert. Aber um sich da überhaupt sicher zu sein, dass man das kann, dass das auch ein Ansatz ist, der verfolgungs- und investitionswürdig ist, hat man jetzt schon mal einen einzelnen Satelliten hochgeschickt, ohne jetzt weite Laser irgendwo durch den Raum zu schicken, nur mit einer oder zwei freifliegenden Massen. Der befindet sich am Lagrange-Punkt 1.
Am Lagrange-Punkt 1, das ist der zwischen der Erde und der Sonne.
Also fliegt immer mit der Sonne, mit der Erde mit.
Fliegt mit der Erde mit. Das ist so ein Punkt, da kann man nicht direkt hin. Das ist kein physikalischer Punkt oder so.
Das ist so ein Bereich.
Aber das ist ein Bereich und im Moment läuft dieser Satellit also um diesen Punkt herum in einem relativ weiten Orbit. Also wir haben immer so, je nachdem zu welcher Phase der Mission, aber wir haben so ungefähr 20 Grad Abstand zur Sonne.
Das sieht so aus wie so eine Acht, die da gebogen wird.
Das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so ein Pringles-Chip. Das sieht so ganz eigenartig aus. Erst ist der Orbit nicht eben, sondern ist so ein bisschen gebogen und dann auch noch so ein bisschen eigenartig verformt. Das liegt halt einfach daran, dass der mit der Erde um die Sonne mit muss.
Aber das ist jetzt auch nichts, was jetzt groß neu erfunden werden muss. Das hat man schon mit Herschel und Planck am Lagrange-Punkt 2 auch gemacht.
Am Lagrange-Punkt 2 und die ESA-Mission, die tatsächlich noch immer in L1 ist, ist so hoch, das Solar Heliophysics Observatory, das ist eine gemeinsame Mission mit der NASA. Aber es ist halt auch eine ESA-Mission, die befindet sich, dass der Punkt, der L1-Punkt, ist halt aus naheliegenden Gründen für die Sonnenbeobachtung sehr geeignet.
Für die Erdbeobachtung, es gibt ja auch noch diese schöne Discover-Mission mit der NASA.
Es gibt eine amerikanische Mission, ja. Interessanterweise ist tatsächlich die Erde für Lisa Parst sein dann ein Problem, weil wir die Sonnenzellen und die ganze thermische Isolation, dass wir also sozusagen die Temperatur des Satelliten möglichst gleichmäßig ist, die sehen wir auf der, die sind natürlich auf der Sonnenseite des Satelliten. Und auf der Rückseite des Satelliten, wenn man zwischen Erde und Sonne steht, ist natürlich die Erde. Und man sieht immer die vollbeleuchtete Erde. Das heißt, es gibt einen Effekt, wo das von der Sonne, von der Erde reflektierte Sonnenlicht Temperaturschwankungen auf dem Satelliten macht. Und daran muss man dann auch irgendwann mal denken, dass man den Satelliten so baut, dass das keine Auswirkungen hat.
Aber warum wird dann Lisa Parst von da nicht auf L2 geschickt, wie das Planck und Herschel gemacht haben, ins Dunkle, wenn man es eh kalt haben will?
Wenn man es eh kalt haben will, L2 wäre eine Option gewesen. Lisa Parst hat eine etwas, sagen wir mal, komplizierte Geschichte. Und letztendlich werden solche Sachen, welcher Orbit entschieden wird, dann auch, hängt dann auch an der Verfügbarkeit von Staatssystemen ab, was man da machen kann, mit welchem Staatssystem und welcher Masse der Satelliten man wohin kommt. Und L2 ist ein Stückchen schwieriger zu erreichen als L1. Himmelsmechanik ist so, keine Ahnung. Also das ist so die Sache, was wenn man... Das sind Sachen, wo die Leute das einem vorrechnen und sagen, gut...
Was so und so viel...
Man braucht einen anderen Launcher. Wir haben ja dieses Vega-Staatssystem genommen, das ist ein extrem, diese kleine europäische Rakete. Und Hörschel und Plank, na gut, die sind zu zweit gestartet, das ist ein bisschen unfair, aber die haben eine Ariane gehabt. Und... Also, letztendlich spielen da auch solche Gründe eine Rolle in der Orbit-Auswahl.
Okay, aber wäre das jetzt sozusagen kein Problem gewesen, könnte man jetzt genauso gut gehen, dass der Spaß auch mit den zwei...
Man hätte auch ganz woanders hingehen können. Man hätte auch in ganz anderen Orbit gehen können. Der Orbit ist für uns nicht... ist nur insofern entscheidend, dass man genug Strom hat. Man muss mit dem Satelliten sprechen können, weil man die Daten irgendwann mal haben möchte. Und man darf nicht zu dicht an der Erde sein, weil sonst die Gravitationskraft der Erde ein Problem ist. Und da hätte man auch ganz woanders hingehen können, aber irgendwann...
Bei den Lagrange-Punkten ist es halt super, weil das hat mehr oder weniger weit weg, aber konstanter Abstand.
Genau, und man hat halt... Man kann es halt leicht mit dem Satelliten kommunizieren und all sowas. Es ist also, sagen wir mal... .Convenience-Orbit. Dadurch, dass diese Mission nichts beobachten muss, wie Hörschel oder wie Plank, wo man dann darauf angewiesen ist, dass die Sonne nicht im Blickfeld ist und all sowas, spielt das keine Rolle.
Hier merkt man aber auch, dass die Raumfahrt wirklich schon einen weiten Weg genommen hat und gut aufgestellt ist für Missionen, die man sich, glaube ich, vor gar nicht so langer Zeit nicht hätte auch in einem Traum vorstellen können.
Das ist wirklich wahr. Also wenn man sich so anschaut, man hat ja immer so ein bisschen die Albträume, was alles schiefgehen kann in so einer Mission, aber es ist wirklich so, als der Projektmanager sagte mir zu mir vor zwei Wochen, du musst einfach mal den Ingenieuren vertrauen. Und dann sagen, da ist ein wahres Wort dran. Also die Leute, die bauen halt Sachen, damit sie funktionieren und nicht damit sie kaputt gehen. Also funktionieren die auch. Und deswegen sind viele Sachen auch so teuer und so aufwendig, weil natürlich ganz viele Sachen immer wieder getestet werden müssen und immer wieder doppelt und dreifach und müssen die entsprechenden Vibrationstests und thermischen Tests und sowas durchstehen und müssen trotzdem noch funktionieren. Aber dafür funktionieren sie dann halt auch.
Jetzt würde ich gerne noch mal das mit diesen fliegenden Massen noch mal kurz genauer anschauen. Vor allem habe ich noch nicht verstanden, wo eigentlich der Detektor ist oder wo der Laser-Detektor dann zukünftig sein wird.
Der Laser-Detektor, also was wir haben auf den Satelliten, das ist die sogenannte optische Bank. Das kennt man vielleicht noch aus der Schule aus dem Physikunterricht. Das war so ein dreieckiges Ding, auf dem man so die Linsen draufgestellt hatte. Davon ist bei uns nicht mehr viel zu sehen. Das ist eine große Glasplatte aus einer Glaskeramik. Cerodur, manche Leute kennen das aus ihrem Küchenherd, aus dem Ceranfeld, genau. Das hat halt den Vorteil, dass sich das thermisch praktisch nicht ausdehnt. Und da stehen halt kleine Spiegel drauf, die das Licht an die entsprechenden Stellen lenken. Und da stehen dann auch Fotodioten drauf, die die Signale registrieren. Und nun hab ich gesagt, wir messen den Abstand zwischen zwei Testmassen. Das ist zwar richtig, aber völlig unpraktisch. Die sind ja ein paar Millionen Kilometer voneinander entfernt. Also wir haben auf jedem Satelliten Teleskope, die das Laserlicht aussenden und das Laserlicht empfangen. Und direkt hinter dem Teleskop wird das Laserlicht gemessen, die Phase des Laserlichtes. Und dann haben wir ein zweites Interferometer, was den Abstand von der Testmasse zu dieser optischen Bank misst. Und wenn man die beiden dann addiert, dann spielt die optische Bank, die ist so stabil, die spielt keine Rolle. Man misst den Abstand zwischen Testmasse und Satellit. Man misst den Abstand zwischen Satellit und Satellit. Und man misst den Abstand zwischen Satellit und Testmasse. Die drei baut man zusammen. Und dann hat man den Abstand zwischen Testmasse und Testmasse. Das hat aber rein praktische Gründe. Einfach, weil es nicht praktikabel ist, auf ein paar Millionen Kilometer das Licht auf eine Testmasse zu senden. Das wird nichts. Das muss man ein bisschen geschickter bauen, dass das dann auch funktioniert. So wird das bei Lisa werden. Und diese Testmassen sind halt goldbeschichtete kleine Würfel, die auch Gold-Platin-Legierung einfach aus Massegründen und man möchte möglichst unempfindlich gegenüber magnetischen Feldern sein. Da hat sich herausgestellt, dass das eine recht gute Mischung ist. Die sind fast komplett unmagnetisch.
Das heißt, die bestehen auch nur aus Gold und Platin?
Die bestehen aus Gold und Platin. Und Gold und Platin, wenn man die Mischung zusammenkippt, das sieht extrem enttäuschend aus. Das ist so ein schmutziges Grau. Es ist zwar teuer, aber es sieht trotzdem hässlich aus. Die Oberfläche ist dünn mit Gold beschichtet, um die elektrischen Eigenschaften des Golds, die sehr schön sind, zu bekommen. Gleichzeitig reflektiert man Gold in dem Frequenzbereich des Lasers, den wir haben, auch sehr gut. Wir nehmen Infrarotlaser, auch aus praktischen Gründen, weil der schön funktioniert.
Warum ist Platin dabei?
Gold alleine, wenn du diese Küchenmagneten hast, diese kleinen Neodym-Magneten, die sind so vielleicht so groß wie ein Cent oder so was, extrem starke Magneten. Und wenn du ein Goldring hast, dann wirst du sehen, dass die daran, beim Platinring bleiben sie hängen und der Goldring stößt das ganz leicht ab. Und das liegt einfach daran, dass in starken Magnetfeldern eben auch Gold und Platin eine gewisse sich in Richtung oder in Richtung zu einem Magnetfeld bewegen oder aus einem Magnetfeld raus bewegen. Und das wollen wir natürlich nicht haben, weil wir auch im Weltall Magnetfelder haben. Und wir wollen diese Testmassen möglichst wenig an Magnetfelder koppeln. Und wenn man da genau die richtige Mischung nimmt, so 25, 75 oder so was, dann heben die sich in ihrer Wirkung auf. Das ist die Idee. Und wie gesagt, dann kommt da was raus, was so ein bisschen aussieht und sagt, dafür haben wir so viel Geld ausgegeben. Aber ja, man denkt ja, man denkt...
Deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich goldbeschichtet.
Nein, das hat elektrische Gründe. Aber die Originalbilder waren schon ein bisschen auch mal. Das ist ja nicht so toll.
Okay, also man könnte zumindest sagen, da sind jetzt so zwei Goldwürfe im Weltall.
Genau, zwei Kilo wiegen die und sind so ungefähr 4,5 Zentimeter Kantenlänge.
Und was ist jetzt schon getestet worden? Also der Flug, also wann war der Start? Das war letztes Jahr.
3. Dezember sind wir gestartet. Wir sind jetzt immer noch in der sogenannten Commissioning Phase. Das ist also sozusagen das Ausprobieren der Instrumente mit der Unterstützung der Industrie, die uns die Instrumente gebaut hat. Da ist ja auch immer ganz viel Software und entsprechende Schnittstellen dabei, die ausprobiert werden müssen. In der Phase sind wir noch, aber wir haben bereits unsere kleinen Triebwerke ausprobiert. Das sind einfach nur so, die haben nur Stickstoff an Bord, wie eine Druckluftflasche im Wesentlichen. Und dann haben wir von den Amerikanern auch noch kleine Triebwerke. Die senden kleine elektrisch geladene Tröpfchen aus. Die sind dann nochmal ein bisschen schwächer in der Leistung. Wir brauchen nur ganz wenig Vorschub, aber wir müssen relativ schnell reagieren können. Und wir müssen relativ genau reagieren können. Deswegen können wir keine normalen Raketentriebwerke nehmen. Die sind zwar unglaublich stark, aber die haben halt nur an oder aus. Und beides nicht so richtig zuverlässig. Also wenn man denen das Signal ansendet, dann kann das sein, dass die halt eine zwei Zehntel Sekunden später angehen. Und bei aus, das ist noch ein bisschen schwieriger. Die darf uns überzeugen, auch mal wieder auszugehen. Und das können wir uns nicht erlauben. Das heißt, wir haben da nur so, wir nennen das Cold Gas, also einfach nur Gas, Stickstoff, das da ausströmt. Und die Kräfte, die wir da ausüben können, sind sehr gering. Und die haben wir schon getestet, wir wissen, dass die funktionieren. Wie gesagt, wir haben gestern die Testmassen aus der mechanischen Halterung befreit und haben sie jetzt nur noch auf elektrostatischen Feldern. Das wissen wir auch, dass das funktioniert. Die Laser-Messung, also die Interferometrie zwischen Testmassen, da wissen wir auch, dass die funktioniert. Die funktioniert noch nicht perfekt. Das liegt daran, dass die Testmassen noch nicht perfekt aufeinander ausgerichtet sind. Das müssen wir auch noch morgen machen. Mit den elektromagnetischen Feldern, genau. Die werden auch später noch gelegentlich mal benutzt werden müssen, um die wieder sozusagen in Form zu drücken.
Das heißt, diese mechanische Erhaltung war sozusagen erst mal für den Start?
Die mechanische Erhaltung war am Start. Das kannst du dir so vorstellen, das ist ein Gehäuse, da ist es um den Würfel drum herum und da ist an allen Ecken so ein paar Millimeter Platz. Und wenn die Rakete startet, das schüttelt alles ganz gewaltig, dann hat man da also in der Mitte einen 2 kg schweren Würfel, den man in so einem Gehäuse so hin und her schüttelt, da weiß man, da bleibt nach relativ kurzer Zeit nicht mehr viel von übrig. Das heißt, man muss das festhalten. Und das sind 2 kg, das heißt, da muss man kräftig festhalten. Das Problem ist, weiß man auch, wenn man zwei Metalloberflächen kräftig zusammendrückt und lange genug zusammendrückt, dann besteht die Gefahr, dass es da an einzelnen kleinen Stellen die einander kleben bleiben. Das heißt, dann ist die Frage, wie baut man sowas eigentlich, dass man die auch mal wieder loswerden kann. Auf der Erde hilft meistens die Schwerkraft, nur die haben wir da ja nicht. Ja, und da ist also viel Hirnschmeiß in die Lösung geflossen, dass man dann sozusagen sukzessive von hohen Kräften auf niedere Kräfte, auf ganz kleine Kräfte, auf noch kleinere Kräfte runtergehen kann, damit man sozusagen diese Adhésionskräfte, die dann möglicherweise da sind oder nicht da sind, wieder los wird. Es hat sich herausgestellt, da waren wir vielleicht ein bisschen übervorsichtig. Das hat also relativ gut geklappt. Gestern Nachmittag war so ein bisschen eine kleine Krise, weil sich die eine Testmasse beschlossen hat, sie möchte sich lieber in die Ecke verziehen. Aber da haben wir natürlich die Möglichkeit, die da auch wieder rauszuholen. Aber das ist dann immer, wenn man im Kontrollraum sitzt und was passiert, was nicht von vornherein geplant ist, dann gucken natürlich erstmal alle Leute etwas nervös und jetzt lassen wir uns mal überlegen, was wir als nächstes tun. Aber das ist jetzt auch, heute sind wir noch dabei zu gucken, diese Testmassen laden sich im Satelliten elektrisch auf. Einfach dadurch, dass wir Strahlung haben, die durch den Satelliten durchgeht und Energie und Ladung deponiert. Das heißt, wir müssen eine Möglichkeit haben, die Testmassen wieder zu entladen. Normalerweise würde man das machen, indem man da mit einem Kabel dran geht, aber das wollen wir ja gerade nicht. Und das heißt, da muss man sich überlegen, wie entlädt man was, ohne dass man es anfasst. Und dann nimmt man halt UV-Licht. Das heißt, man strahlt die mit UV-Licht an. Dann probieren wir heute aus, wie viel Licht wir genau brauchen, um eine gewisse Ladungsmenge runter oder rauf zu schubsen. Das ist, ich würde sagen, Business as usual. Das ist halt das, was man macht, wenn man sowas ausprobiert. Oder wenn man sowas bekommt, dann muss man die einzelnen Funktionen ausprobieren. Und die eigentliche Messung zum Schluss ist dann relativ unspektakulär. Wir werden einfach diese Testmassen so wenig wie möglich anfassen und mal das Messsignal nehmen und schauen, wie stark wackeln sie denn noch. Das erste Mal, wenn wir das Anfang nächsten Monats im März machen. Und dann hoffen wir mal, dass das, was wir uns vorgenommen haben und so wie wir den Apparat entworfen haben, dass der dann auch die entsprechende Stille da oben produziert. Gravitationswellen werden wir damit leider nicht detektieren können. Dazu ist der Abstand viel zu klein der beiden Würfel. Das ist 40 Zentimeter gegenüber vielen Millionen Kilometern. Das ist schon klar, dass das nichts wird.
Aber darum geht es ja jetzt in den ersten Schritt auch nicht. Es geht darum, einfach totale Ruhe herzustellen. Das ist wahrscheinlich überhaupt das erste Mal, dass etwas kontrolliert frei schweben gelassen wird über einen längeren Zeitraum.
Unseres Wissen ist nach, ja. Da muss man immer ein ganz klein bisschen vorsichtig sein in solchen Sachen, weil sowas möglicherweise auch militärische Anwendungen hat. Das heißt, es kann durchaus sein, dass es bereits Satelliten gibt, die sowas können. Aber keiner hat uns was gesagt, wie man es macht. Also das ist sozusagen unseres Wissens das erste Mal, dass so was gemacht wird.
Wie lange wird denn jetzt Lieser Pathfinder betrieben werden müssen, bis man da wirklich meint, Klarheit zu haben?
Also wir haben den Plan erstmal, dass unsere Experimente an Bord laufen erst mal drei Monate. Dann haben die Amerikaner, also die NASA, die auch Triebwerke und Software beigesteuert hat, benutzen sozusagen unsere Testmassen, aber deren Software und deren Triebwerke, um zu schauen, dass das auch funktioniert, weil auch das ist bei noch nicht klar, was wir für Lieser nehmen werden, ob wir die einen oder die anderen oder vielleicht was ganz anderes. Und dann ist sozusagen erst das nominelle halbe Jahr, dass wir gesagt haben, dass wir brauchen um, aber wir haben genug Treibstoff um nochmal ein halbes Jahr oder so was. Und da muss man halt gucken, was sind noch Fragen, die man eigentlich noch ein bisschen genauer beobachten, genauer untersuchen möchte oder was sind Sachen, die wir uns vorher nicht getraut haben. Weil man macht ja dann nur Sachen, von denen man sich sicher ist, dass sie da nichts kaputt machen. Aber vielleicht sind ja Sachen dabei, da würde man ganz gern wissen, wie sie denn kaputt gehen. Also für den Fall, dass mal was passiert. Also zum Ende der Mission hin werden wir sicherlich noch ein paar Sachen ausprobieren, die vielleicht nicht ganz oben auf der Prioritätenliste stehen, aber auch schön werden zu wissen. Viel länger als ein Jahr wird es nicht werden, da haben wir nicht genug Treibstoff an Bord.
Und was für eine Laufzeit lässt sich dann bei Lisa realisieren? Ich meine, das schließt man ja auch einmal hin und irgendwann muss man es aufgeben.
Also die Lebensdauer von Lisa, sagen wir mal, abgesehen von irgendwelchen elektronischen Störungen oder sowas, also dass ein Laser kaputt geht oder sowas, wird eigentlich nur durch den Treibstoff bestimmt, den wir mithaben. Und das liegt ein bisschen daran, dass dieses gleichseitige Dreieck, von dem ich gesprochen habe, das wird in einen speziellen Orbit gebracht. Und der ist stabil, also das Dreieck, das bleibt natürlich ein Dreieck, es sind drei Satelliten, was anderes bleibt ja nicht übrig, aber es bleibt auch mehr oder weniger gleichseitig. Aber so ein bisschen zerrt doch die Erde an der Konstellation. Und das heißt, die fängt sich immer stärker an zu bewegen. Und irgendwann hat man halt nicht mehr genügend Treibstoff und auch nicht mehr genügend Reserve in den entsprechenden Lasern, um das noch auffangen zu können. Und das ist aber im Bereich 10 Jahre überhaupt kein Problem. Also da ist dann bei vielen unserer Missionen, muss man sagen, die sind dann, wenn die erst mal XMM oder auch Soho ist ein Beispiel, die sind für ein paar Jahre designt und leben dann 20 Jahre im Orbit. Und im Prinzip kostet die ja nichts mehr, wenn die erst mal da oben sind. Aber natürlich muss am Boden noch ein Team unterhalten werden für die Operations. Also man muss mit dem Satelliten gelegentlich mal Kontakt aufnehmen, man muss die Daten runterbekommen, man muss Planungen machen und sowas. Aber wir planen jetzt, also wir planen ist groß gesagt, wir haben ja noch keine Mission Lisa im Programm als solches. Aber weniger als fünf Jahre für so eine Mission für den Preis ergibt wenig Sinn. Also wenn man dann da schon mal oben ist, möchte man auch eine Weile rummessen. Und dann muss man mal schauen, also wenn alles gut geht, sagen wir, also man plant immer, man hat Treibstoff immer für ein bisschen länger an Bord. Und da, also zehn Jahre kriegen wir bestimmt hin, wenn es sein muss, wenn nichts kaputt geht.
Teleskope, die in den Weltall geschickt wurden, vor allem Hubble, haben ja die Astronomie durchgeschüttelt wie nichts vorher. Ich denke, dass sich auch dort keiner vorher ein Bild gemacht hat. Was Hubble alles an Bildern und Informationen liefern wird. Ähnliches hatten wir schon bei den Röntgen-Teleskopen. Also es sind immer wieder Türen aufgestoßen worden. Das weiß man natürlich jetzt hier nicht, ob das jetzt hier auch so sein wird. Vielleicht ist es ja auch alles anders. Aber nicht zuletzt hat jetzt gerade das letzte halbe Jahr gezeigt, dass im Bereich von Gravitationswellen eine Menge Musik drin ist. Und das nicht nur im hörbaren Bereich, sondern dass es hier sozusagen gelingen könnte, mit so einem Instrument quasi der Weltraumforschung, der Astronomie und der Wissenschaft auch als solchen quasi so einen neuen Fühlerarm zu verpassen, der einfach etwas abdeckt, was bisher von noch nichts anderem abgedeckt worden ist.
Also das ist auch ganz klar eines der großen Selling Points von so einer Mission, dass man was macht, was von dem man vorhin, zu dem man vorher nicht in der Lage war, das ist auch eine Sache, die Technologie, sowas zu bauen, haben wir noch nicht so schrecklich lange. Und zum anderen natürlich auch dieser Entdeckungsraum, den man da aufmacht, dass man also tatsächlich nicht weiß, was da passiert. Man kann keine Missionen aufbauen, einfach nur auf dem Versprechen, da wird schon irgendwas sein. Man muss also auch schon klar sagen, guck mal, hier haben wir die Quellen, von denen wir ganz sicher wissen, dass die da sind. Und hier haben wir die Quellen, davon haben wir auch viele. Quellen, von denen wir vielleicht nicht ganz sicher sind. Aber wenn wir die nicht sehen, das wäre schon eine riesengroße Überraschung. Und dann halt die nächste Sache, wo man sagt, ja und dann ist da der ganze große Bereich, von dem wir noch tatsächlich noch nicht wissen, wie es aussieht. Und das ist eigentlich für mich sozusagen der Charme und der Sinn von Forschung im Großen und Ganzen. Ich meine, wir forschen nicht an Dingen, von denen wir von vornherein ganz genau wissen, was dabei rauskommt. Also es gibt diesen flapsigen Spruch, wenn wir wüssten, was wir tun würden, würden wir es nicht Wissenschaft nennen. Aber der ist sehr flapsig und dem sollte man vielleicht nicht unbedingt den Leuten sagen, die einem das Gehalt zahlen und die Steuern dafür abdrücken, damit wir unsere Experimente machen können. Aber letztendlich ist es genau das. Wir machen das, um Dinge herauszufinden, die wir vorher nicht wussten.
Man weiß nie, was es ist.
Man weiß nicht, was es ist und das ist auch die spannende Sache da dran. Also es kann morgen was passieren, wo wir sagen, das haben wir vorher so nicht gewusst.
Vor allem, wenn Lisa, angenommen Lisa wäre jetzt vor einem halben Jahr schon im All gewesen, würde funktionieren und hätte dieses Ereignis der beiden schwarzen Löcher genauso wie LIGO auch empfangen?
Das wäre nicht passiert, weil wir in dem Bereich unempfindlich sind. Also unser Frequenzbereich liegt deutlich tiefer. Irgendwas im Bereich 30 Hertz oder sowas würde man mit einem Lisa-ähnlichen Detektor nicht sehen. Das liegt einfach daran, dass die, wenn so eine Gravitationswelle vorbeikommt, dann hätte ich gesagt, die macht dieses Quetschen und Strecken. Und eine volle Wellenlänge quetscht und streckt einmal. So, das heißt, wenn die zweite Wellenlänge kommt, die quetscht und streckt wieder. Aber dann ist die erste vergessen. Das heißt, wenn das Licht zu lange läuft, dann sammelt das, dann heben sich die einzelnen Beiträge auf und nur das letzte bisschen zählt. Und dann haben wir nichts mehr von unserem Arm, der, sagen wir mal, mehrere Millionen Kilometer lang ist. Vielleicht sind es dann nur noch die letzten 10.000 Kilometer. Und dafür ist unsere Messempfindlichkeit zu gering. Also 30 Hertz ist weit jenseits dessen, was wir messen können. Bei einem Herz würde ich sagen, na okay, vielleicht. Aber da haben die LIGO-Leute ein erhebliches Problem. Bei einem Herz, also wir haben wenig...
Was heißt, es gibt gar keine Überlappung?
Es gibt keine synchrone Überlappung. Damit meine ich, wir haben überlappende Quellen. Wir werden also, wenn Lisa im Orbit ist, werden wir Quellen sehen, die auch LIGO sieht.
Aber andere Aspekte.
Aber wir sehen sie eine Million Jahre früher. Also zum Beispiel die typische Sache Neutronensterne, dass die umeinander kreisen. Wir sehen die Phase, bei dem die noch umeinander kreisen. LIGO sieht die Phase, wo sie zusammenstoßen. Alles klar. Deswegen sage ich, keine synchrone Gleichheit der Quellen. Wir sehen tatsächlich die gleichen Quellen, aber nur in einer sehr viel früheren Phase ihrer Entwicklung. Das ist natürlich auch schon mal eine interessante Sache, wenn man sagt, wenn ich mit einem solchen Detektor eine große Zahl von diesen Doppelsternen und Doppelneutronensternen sehe zum Beispiel, dann weiß ich natürlich, die müssen ja irgendwie enden. Das heißt, damit kann man natürlich sofort ausrechnen, wie viele pro Jahr eigentlich verschmelzen. Damit kann man ausrechnen, wie viele müsste eigentlich ein Detektor am Boden sehen. Wenn die beiden Zahlen zusammenpassen, ist alles gut. Das ist das langweilige Szenario. Das spannende Szenario ist, wenn diese beiden Zahlen nicht zusammenpassen. Entweder, wenn die viel mehr sehen, dann muss man sich fragen, wo kommen die eigentlich alle her? Oder wenn die nichts sehen, dann kann man sich fragen, wo bleiben die eigentlich alle? Das sind die typischen, sagen wir mal, die überlappende Wissenschaft zwischen den beiden Bereichen. Oder wenn die bodengestützten Detektoren ganz viele von diesen 30 Sonnenmassen-Systemen sehen, die würden wir auch in einer frühen Phase der Entwicklung sehen. Muss man sich auch fragen, sehen wir die? Wenn ja, wenn alles gut ist, dann sagt man, na ja schön, dann sehen wir sie auch. Wenn nicht, dann muss man sich fragen, wo kommen sie eigentlich her und wo gehen sie hin? Das ist die gleiche Frage. Es ist auch kein Zufall, dass die wissenschaftliche Community dort eigentlich noch relativ zusammenhängt. Wir sind nicht so groß, dass man sich das erlauben könnte, jetzt eine ganz kleine Fraktionsliste zu zersplittern. Die Leute sagen, wir wollen lieber bodendick gestützte Detektoren machen, wir machen lieber weltraum gestützte Detektoren. Da gibt es schon extrem viel Überlapp zwischen den beiden. Zwischen der gesamten wissenschaftlichen Community. Das sind nicht viel mehr als 1200 Leute weltweit. Das Feld ist glücklicherweise noch jung und spannend genug, dass alle noch total enthusiastisch sind und am gleichen Strick ziehen.
Alle Namen standen jetzt auf dem Paper? Alle nicht.
Aber viele. Meiner steht nicht drauf.
Das gibt es doch keinen Nobelpreis.
Den gibt es sowieso nur für ganz wenige. Das ist auch eine interessante soziologische Sache, wie man managt sowas, so eine gigantische Kollaboration, die ja extrem voneinander abhängt. Also die Leute, die jetzt Gravitationswellen gesehen haben, würden das nicht tun können ohne denjenigen, der vor drei Jahren an der Stelle den Laser aufgebaut hat. Obwohl der jetzt vielleicht was ganz anderes macht. Oder der vielleicht an Gravitationswellen gar kein Interesse hat, sondern das ist jemand, der baut gerne Laser. Und das in den Griff zu bekommen und dazu zu sorgen, dass dann auch alle gleichmäßig beteiligt werden an so einer Veröffentlichung, das hat dann den Nachteil, dass man dann 800 Namen da drauf stehen hat. Und keiner so ganz genau weiß, was das dann so bedeuten hat, dass man da drauf steht. Aber auf der anderen Seite kann man sich jetzt auch nicht erlauben, da nur die fünf Namen drauf zu schreiben, die jetzt das Signal gesehen haben.
Es waren noch nicht nur fünf Leute, die dafür gesorgt haben, dass jemand zum Mond fliegt. Das sind halt einfach Anstrengungen von großen Gruppen.
Das ist wahr. Und es hat auch ganz viele Leute und ganz viel Zeit gebraucht, den Kölner Dom zu bauen. Das ist richtig. Trotzdem muss ich sagen, der Ansatz, den LIGO da hat zu sagen, solange es geht, sozusagen nehmen wir alle mit. Man fällt dann irgendwann mal raus aus der Publikationsliste. Wenn man sozusagen seit vier Jahren was anderes macht oder sowas, dann rutscht man langsam raus. Aber doch zumindest erstmal den Versuch zu starten, das sozusagen als eine Gemeinschaft zu behalten und nicht sozusagen da gleich mit den Einzelnen… Das geht auch nicht, weil… Ich meine, das Signal war im September. Jetzt die Pressekonferenz war 11. Februar. Gut, es gab natürlich ausreichend Gerüchte, die zum Schluss hin auch immer, sagen wir mal, detaillierter wurden. Aber bis Mitte Dezember oder sowas ist relativ wenig nach draußen gedrungen.
Aber ihr wusstet alle Bescheid.
Na ja, die Leute, die schon mal in der Community waren, oder ich hab natürlich auch etwas detailliertere Gerüchte gehabt, aber letztlich waren das auch nur Gerüchte. Und wenn man sich ein bisschen mit den Detektoren auskennt, dann kann man sich natürlich schon fragen, warum sehen wir jetzt mit der neuen Version was, aber haben mit der alten Version das nicht gesehen. Und dann kann man sich angucken, wo ist die Empfindlichkeit besser geworden. Und dann kann man sagen, na ja, also dann wird es ja wohl in dem Bereich sein, wo die Empfindlichkeit besser geworden ist, und dann kann man die Frequenz schon mal raten. Wenn man die Frequenz geraten hat, kann man die Massen raten. Wenn man die Massen raten kann, weiß man ungefähr, wie weit das Ding weg war. Also so schlecht waren wir mit unserer internen, sagen wir mal, Kaffee-Ecken-Spekuliererei nicht, ja. Aber ist natürlich was ganz anderes, als man dann Gerücht zu haben oder mal gehört zu haben, da könnte was sein, ist es dann schwarz auf weiß da stehen zu haben.
Aber irgendjemand wird einen Nobelpreis dafür kriegen, das ist klar, oder?
Vermutlich, ja. Würde mich überraschen, wenn es das nicht geben würde. Ob es das nun dieses Jahr passieren wird. Ich hab das Gerücht gehört, dass sozusagen der Anmeldeschluss verstrichen ist, weil die natürlich die königliche Archämie da auch einen relativ langen Vorlauf hat. Weiß ich nicht. Es wird sicherlich einen geben. Wer den bekommen wird, ist eine sehr gute Frage. Da gibt es sicherlich zwar eine sehr kleine Anzahl von Leuten, die in Frage kommen, aber eine Anzahl von Leuten, die immer noch zu groß sind, um sie auf einen Preis zu bekommen. Und da muss man gucken. Also wenn du die Pressekonferenz gesehen hast, da war halt der Ray Weiss und der Kip Thorne, die stehen sicherlich relativ weit oben auf der Liste. Ron Dreever steht auch weit oben auf der Liste, aber Ron ist leider nicht mehr so richtig gesund. Und da weiß man also auch nicht, wie lange Ron noch leben wird. Der Heinz Billing ist halt auch schon sehr, sehr alt. Da muss man sich dann möglicherweise auch beeilen, wenn man dem noch einen Preis geben möchte.
Der wollte ja nicht sterben, bevor die Dinger nicht...
Ja, aber jetzt haben wir es ja.
Vielleicht verlängert er jetzt bis zum Nobelpreis.
Vielleicht ist das Rezept für das geleben. Aber das ist ja auch alles ein bisschen... Ich denke mal, es wird einen Nobelpreis für die Entdeckung geben. Und den wird natürlich nicht die ganze Community bekommen, aber es wird natürlich ein Preis für die ganze Community sein. Der wird auch ziemlich sicher politisch... Auch die Entdeckung hat politisch schon Konsequenzen. Also jetzt nicht, dass Angela Merkel uns angerufen hat oder irgendjemand angerufen hat gesagt, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Aber es ist natürlich so, dass man aus einer, sagen wir mal, Nischen, aus einem Nischenbereich der Astronomie ziemlich weit ins Mittelfeld gerückt ist. Und gut, sowas druckt kein Geld und baut auch keine Satelliten. Aber es ist deutlich angenehmer, sozusagen etwas mehr in der Mitte zu stehen als ganz am Rand. Ob das irgendwelche praktischen Konsequenzen hat, werden wir sehen.
Auf jeden Fall ist eine Menge Musik drin. Hier ist eigentlich noch irgendwas übrig von Einstein, was jetzt noch bewiesen werden muss, oder ist es jetzt durch mit Einstein?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Der Mann hat so viel gemacht. Aber ich glaube, im Gravitationsbereich sind wir erstmal, sind wir mit den Gravitationswellen jetzt erstmal durch. Wenn man ein bisschen weiter guckt, kann man natürlich sagen, wir wissen noch nicht über dunkle Materie, wir wissen noch weniger über dunkle Energie. Das hat natürlich auch weniger Konsequenzen von Einstein als Konsequenzen der Beobachtung. Die müssen wir einfach annehmen, sonst passt die Theorie nicht mehr. Das wäre sicherlich noch was schön wäre, wenn wir da mal zumindest einen Hinweis kriegen könnten von irgendjemandem, um was es da eigentlich geht. Aber ansonsten mit Einstein sind wir erstmal durch, denke ich.
Dunkle Materie und damit verbundene Fragen des Universums, das sind so ein paar Themenwellen, die zumindest durch diese Raumzeit hier auch nochmal durchgedrückt werden und vielleicht für die eine oder andere thematische Krümmung sorgen werden. Aber wir sind jetzt glaube ich erstmal am Ende. Gut. Vielen, vielen Dank.
Gern geschehen, hat viel Spaß gemacht.
Ich wünsche einem viel Erfolg mit den Gold Platin Würfeln und den zukünftigen Projekten. Und vielen Dank natürlich auch an alle Hörerinnen und Hörer. Hier war wieder Raumzeit, die 61.